[Music]
Hey all right we went through like a
time warp there for a minute
guess it's like the next day notice we
all have different clothes on yeah yeah
we got kind of tired like doing that one
show last night I thought well I edited
the first section of this show and it
already and it ended up being over three
hours long
yeah and so you know but we still have
to get to all of our listeners stories
and I still said that I was gonna do
more movie recommendations Netflix ones
to be ones so we'll see how much long
yeah I'm gonna try to keep this to like
an hour an hour and a half okay watch it
like this like this section right here
yeah but I figured like Halloween do
people can watch it in sections or put
it all rather sleep in or something like
that you know what I mean okay I didn't
expect you know what we had last night I
didn't expect that to go that long it's
just because we went off we went off on
so many tangents that it's like I didn't
get to it's the same as a spin and every
one of our specials always that's true I
I'll start my lips will start flapping
and like three hours ago by yeah I know
you're a psycho I have enough material
do I have no material and I'm looking at
that oh god he has about eight hours of
material well yeah because I don't even
guess yeah I didn't even get to most of
this [ __ ] like about Halloween history
and stuff like that but I well like we
were too drunk as she was hilarious
anyway it was pretty it did end up
pretty funny like I watched it back over
today while I was editing it I didn't do
a lot of editing I just mostly liked
slap little pictures people know about
Alawis stuff like everybody knows about
Halloween that's true but it's like you
know I just wanted something to talk
about and riff on yeah there's no
problem with that me around but yeah but
like I said you know I you know people
send in stories and I need to get to
those so apologies that it's you know
that it took this long to get to it may
have all put in like the description
it's like if you stories like a talk
show man we will talk during a talk show
that's true so again before I get to the
stories I'm just gonna break it up a
little bit with cuz remember I did like
on the last segment I did
shutter recommendations of horror movies
so now I want to do some that are on
Netflix so again I'm adding a caveat
it's like you know don't like shout at
me in the comments if you didn't like
this movie if you watched it on my
recommendation and then like you're
telling me I suck and stuff like that
these are just movies I liked okay so
okay I died a couple times before yeah
we recommended what was it wasn't it oh
yeah oh maybe it was the biggest waste
of time he didn't get it I guess not
you didn't get it but that's the thing
it's like you can't that's right it's
like well I can't it's like I I will
recommend movies to people if they ask
me to you but it's like or if I know
what their taste is you know I mean or
if they specifically say I want a movie
like XYZ then I'll go oh there's this
woman it's like that but a lot of times
I don't really like to make
recommendations just like random people
because for that very reason because
then people watch it and they'll blame
you for whatever reason I don't know
what it is yeah okay how could the ten
it'd be a waste of time that's what I
mean that's a [ __ ] awesome motivation
[ __ ] there are some movies like
there are some movies that I don't
understand like how people don't like
them like I know people are all
different in blah blah blah but it's
like there there's a handful of movies
that if you don't like them there's like
something wrong with you you know it's
just a creepy movie it was and I don't
see how like well I don't know with the
tenant I guess you have to be patient
that's that's one thing and you're
dealing with Roman Polanski and you
don't know what's important what's not
important but in towards that third act
you start starts all starts coming
together yeah and I guess some people
just thought into that kind of
slow-moving kind of tension and
alienation and you know it's kind of
like that light house movie was like
that we saw the other day yeah we're
kind of just builds up weirder and
weirder you're not really sure what's
happening it's funny because like I was
watching a couple of other um you know
horror guys that I liked like on YouTube
cuz I was curious like what they all
thought of it they all loved it they
thought it was like fantastic light
house yeah and a lot of them said the
same [ __ ] you said that
and that I said that it made you feel
like you were there and it felt like it
felt like an actual old movie a couple
people did compare it to Eraserhead
so you know so it's it's getting like
really good reviews like a lot of people
would bomb I mean it might financially
bomb but I feel like that's one that's
like gonna be like an instant cult
classic just because it's so unique like
you know you you've never seen anything
like that before yeah you know I
understand that movie yeah the
understanding towards it yeah yeah you
better but like I said if I feel like
you know people that are aware of you
know Robert Eggers other movies and like
what types of what type of movie it is
and it's a 24 studios which usually does
like arthouse horror yeah so I feel like
most people if they're not stupid and
they they shouldn't be there then they
shouldn't go see it if they don't think
they're gonna like be into that type of
thing if you don't like weird movies
don't go see it because it's weird yeah
but it's weird in a good way I mean I
like weird movies some people don't run
speaking of Robert Edgar's his first
movie like I said the much-beloved the
witch is on Netflix as of now and so
that is my first recommendation
seriously go see that it's not a lot
like the lighthouse other than you know
being a period piece and being like an
Old English and stuff like that but kind
of you know similar countries like
isolationist family and witchcraft and
all that kind of stuff but it's like a
really really really good movie another
similar one that's on Netflix it's not
well I guess it is kind of similar but
it's called apostle and it's about I
can't remember what year it set but it's
also a period piece and it's like about
this cult that either kidnaps this woman
or like she willingly goes there and
then they won't let her leave so like
her brother is going there pretending to
be a cult member like so he can rescue
her that's also very good so check that
one out also you get to see someone's a
big drill like in to the top of
someone's head and slow motion and it's
pretty disgusting I also recently
watched one I had been seeing this one
on Netflix for a long time and it's like
I was always kinda like that's
it's kind of good but then I'm like oh I
don't know and it's like I just never
was never in the mood for it but then I
saw like a couple other people like on a
couple other channels like recommend it
so I decided to sit down I watched it
was surprisingly good and it's called
clinical and it's about a woman who's
like a she's a trauma psychiatrist and I
guess she she feels guilty because this
one patient that she had like ends up
killing herself or something like that
so she stops doing it so she's having
trauma of her own and then like she gets
this one patient who's been in a
horrible accident like his face was
disfigured and stuff and she feels bad
for him so she decides to go back into
trauma psychology to help him out and
weirdness and Sue's you know Ryan um you
might be able to see where it's going
cuz I kind of saw where it was going but
it's like a really good like tense
thriller type of movie also if you like
sort of game style stuff like saw you
know anything like that would you rather
it was actually surprisingly enjoyable
Jeffrey Combs is in it and he is always
a delight he plays like this horrible
billionaire who who has like a dinner
party every so often and people like
that need money get invited and he's
like basically if you win the game this
at this dinner party then you will get
all your bills taking care of forever
like you'll have just like all the money
that you need and so everybody that goes
it's like all these different kind of
people and obviously the game is just
gets like worse and worse remember that
yeah Jeffery comes in it he played like
this weird as [ __ ] man I'll give him the
lowdown on that he tells him okay for
the next round you have to stab her in
the leg that kind of stuff like well I
don't want to do that as well you don't
do that then that means you know then
you got a whip this guy but like you had
to choose wrong as it was would you
rather it's like so would you rather
yeah but then there was like penalties
of like if you don't do this then we
drowned you to death there are that kind
of stuff yeah well they would shoot you
if you tried to get this right because
like he did originally like cuz it
started out
it starts out pretty mild has sasha grey
porn star in it yeah she's been a couple
movies since then she was good in she
was in that circle movie as well too I
think they giving them ultimatums you
either do this or that which one is it
and like there's two horrible things
like yeah get like get your lips cut off
or we we got to dunk your head
underneath the water for five minutes
for yeah two minutes or for a minute
that was a lot it was more levels well
one of the more challenges was what he
did on one round cuz it started out like
I said it started out pretty mild like
you know oh the vegetarian he's like oh
I'll give you $5,000 if you eat all the
meat on your plate you know to the drunk
he's like hey down this whole bottle of
scotch and I'll give you 50 grand or
something like that yeah but then [ __ ]
start getting worse and worse it's like
either electrocute the person next to
you or electrocute yourself you know
what I mean either stab this woman in
the leg or whip this guy in the back um
then it was something like saw horrible
[ __ ] then he started doing stuff like
you can either do what's on the card
like you in the front of you or you can
do what's on this card that you can't
see yes right like cuz he wants like a
show like a devil you know double you
don't know it's like a game show of
death yeah and if somebody says I [ __ ]
I'm out here they just shoot they just
shoot you and there and the way the game
is we'll only have one survivor yeah
that's that's how you wins yeah it's how
you win so like I said if you're really
into that type of thing because I kind
of like those yeah
yeah it was it was a little bit like
ready or not the recent one that we saw
it was similar kind of premise but yeah
so yeah great was in it I really liked
that one yeah she was looking good - she
was the designated [ __ ] yeah she was a
[ __ ] well like I said she's kind of
doing down rave though she did I
remember she took the drowning test
she's like okay it didn't work though
well yeah I think the thing I think she
had the thing that said either put your
head under water for two minutes or
three minutes or and then she was like
no I'll take the card and that said put
your head under water for four or five
minutes yeah so yeah that was that um
also and I know like I said that I
talked about how much I don't really
like found footage but I should note
that there are some found footage some
footage their movies that I really like
and a couple of them are on this list
one of them is called creep now this is
not the movie that had franka potente in
it this is the one with Mark Duplass
it's like a found footage one about a
guy who's like a videographer and he
answers a Craigslist ad for a dude that
ostensibly wants him to film a day in
his life because supposedly his wife is
pregnant but he has terminal cancer and
he's gonna die before the baby is born
so he wants the baby to like know his
dad and stuff so so this guy goes in to
videotape this guy and this dude just
gets weirder and weirder and weirder and
it's just like really good it's like
really I think a lot of it was even
improvised because basically just like
two characters but it's just like so
creepy and on edge you're not sure like
you knows like bad shits gonna go down
but it doesn't go exactly the way you
expect you know I mean they also made a
sequel which is just called creep 2 and
that is also on Netflix and is also
surprisingly very good so you should
probably check both of those out um if
you like kind of creepy slow-burn type
before like I do then you should see the
black coats daughter that's also very
good I'm not gonna spoil too much about
that because that's another one where
it's kind of better if you don't really
know too much about it like going into
it if you like sort of sees style horror
home invasion style horror with a little
bit of a twist you should see hush which
I believe was directed by Mike Flanagan
and so it's basically like a an author a
deaf woman and she's at this isolated
cabin like writing a book and gets
attacked by it like a stranger but she
can't hear him you know what I mean so
there's like a whole new dynamic - like
the home invasion style but it's really
really well done it really is
suspenseful horror comedies
welcome to Willits which I think we
might have talked about before about
remember the guys about the guy and the
woman and they're kind of like crazy
conspiracy nuts and like they live out
like grow pot and stuff yeah yeah and
then and he thinks everyone is aliens
yeah you know yeah they kill her math
and stuff yeah it was like called
emerald ice or whatever it was called
yeah that was a good one I liked that
one a lot we did a whole review on that
one I think
I don't think we did a whole review on
it but I think we talked about it yeah
another show that we had yeah the
director that film thanked us for
mentioning it didn't he yeah I think you
might have yeah but yeah that's a really
good one and that's still I liked I
think because we watched that one and
one called Ava's possessions at the same
time which I also really liked but I
don't think Ava's possessions is on
Netflix anymore but welcome to wellit's
is still there yeah also if you like
horror comedy you got to see Tucker and
Dale vs. evil which is still on there
it's been on there a long time and if
you haven't seen that you've got to see
that cuz I that's another movie that I
don't understand how anyone could not
love that movie which one Tucker and
Dale vs. evil
yeah it's delightful it's a delightful
gory it's hilarious it's hilarious and
heartfelt and like the two characters of
the middle that are just so like
charming and lovable like just you know
you can see you got jump into a wood
chipper it's fantastic I like that maybe
a lot it's kind of luck there was like
an evil dad type movie yeah Tom but like
yes and it's like a cabin in the woods
movie but like a reversal you know what
I mean where those are like the good
guys that if you like that kind of tone
of horror which I prefer that yeah tone
most of the time it's a lot of fun yeah
I mean that's a really fun babysitter
gorian but fine yeah like you know but
you know I like a lot of different kinds
of horror movies but I tend to like that
that tone yeah you know another one that
get away with a lot of [ __ ] yeah you
know if there's imperfections in the
movie doesn't matter because you're not
really supposed to be taking it
seriously yeah it's just supposed to be
a good time right yeah um another one
along those lines and this is the one
that we watched when Shana and Erik
wherever here was terrified yeah yeah
that was that was like a really it's
like really low budget yeah it's like
really simple as matter though it's just
like a scary clown that's like
terrorizing these girls on Halloween
night yeah but we had a blast but the
blast watching this thank for your buck
on - I'm terrified yeah it's super gory
I was like it was it's really really
gory but I thought it was a lot of fun
some people didn't like just thought it
was stupid or whatever but it's like I I
thought it was great I had a I had a
[ __ ] really good time watching that
baby horror movies are stupid you still
like them that's true well it has to be
stupid in a particular way yeah no they
had a great as a tone of the movie was
perfect yeah it didn't take itself
seriously
no just this [ __ ] schizo geeky
[ __ ] evil clown yeah
just laughs yeah but yeah but it was
that [ __ ] that it was doing yeah yeah
like I said didn't like somebody get cut
in half it was all kind of crazy [ __ ]
it's face expressions we walked it [ __ ]
I feel like it's weird because I feel
like that movie made more of like a
cultural impact than because I've seen
that costumes of that clown now like our
clown and that was just like a nothing
budget movie but it really kind of like
it was well done yeah and I mean in a
world where Pennywise exists and there's
like evil clowns and [ __ ] like that but
I think I'm kind of getting over the
evil clown thing but you know it can
still be done well it's just like they
didn't all come out the same time of
course yeah getting oversaturated like
zombies yeah you know it's just one that
you can watch it's up there kind of like
the old Friday the 13th before they got
super super corny you know I mean those
before Jason went to space yeah yeah
yeah what's called tera fire yeah tera
fire was kind of like that but with a
comedy twist yeah yeah like I said it
would it really it was kind of
tongue-in-cheek in that way um
yeah also speaking of like weird
uncomfortably funny kind of movies and I
think we've mentioned this one before
tusks
oh yeah the Kevin Smith movie I see that
one
it's a weird [ __ ] what am I seeing you
know it's definitely a what the [ __ ]
that I just watch chilling it is it's
like it's disturbing and sad but it's
also like fucked-up idli funny yeah you
know enemies dude who's not much of a
man really he's kind of a [ __ ] up and
he's like a podcaster right yeah yeah
and he meets up with this old dude who's
[ __ ] in a wheelchair he's [ __ ]
weird as [ __ ] and he starts telling
basically he starts talent he ends up
telling the story about how he got
stranded on an iceberg yeah with a with
a single walrus and he and that walrus
sexy sexy Don that damn on that thing on
that ice for how long was it long run
even remembers a long time and I was
bringing him fish and all kinds of [ __ ]
and he he missed that walrus he loved
him he had all this weird fixations with
walruses and I'm just gonna leave it at
that dude wanted his walrus back and
he's just this [ __ ] creepy old I
really liked because the thing is we was
on Netflix actually Kevin Smith he's
making it's sort of like a loose trilogy
the first movie and is called yoga
hosers and that is on Netflix also but I
still haven't got around to watching
that that's one of those loved it or
hated type of movies I guess tusk is too
but I feel like more people liked this
one than like to yoga hosers I think
he's making a third one called the Moose
Jaw or something like that that's kind
of supposed to be in a similar tone but
the only thing we knew about this one
was our friend Shana she basically said
watch tusk she didn't tell us what it
was about
she didn't nothing and it's like [ __ ] me
and her like a lot of the same movies so
I was just kind of like okay well we'll
watch that tonight like after she left
and I was just like so we had no idea
like where it was going or anything all
we knew was the title it's [ __ ]
disturbing
there was some hidden meanings to it you
know having to do with tears of a walrus
and you know what I can't spoil it if
you guys haven't seen it yeah it's it's
messed up yeah it's a bit like I said
it's gonna be one of those ones that
it's divisive you're either gonna love
it or hate it but you just let the
weirdness well if you're into horror
movies I don't see why you wouldn't just
let the weirdness overwhelm you just let
it let it flow yeah I would probably put
it on par something like misery where
the the villain is harmless looking at
first but he get any of you and they
started doing things to you you
yes it's like when you first made that
comparison I was like wow but then yeah
no I see what you're saying you can't
get away if we can't get away yeah yeah
that's yeah it's making you do some that
they want to do being a prisoner and a
really [ __ ] up thing yeah being a
prisoner of a [ __ ] psychopath yeah um
okay so another one that is on there and
I recommend this to you pretty much
everybody especially if you really like
sort of culty horror but also this is
more like a suspense thriller this is
actually one of the tensest movies that
I have ever watched it's called the
invitation and I've seen like a lot of
other people like recommend this to you
and I feel like it doesn't really get
all that much love interestingly it's
sort of like a hidden gem and it's
basically like about this guy and him
and his wife divorce like after their
child died accidentally it's been two
years and the wife is remarried and her
and the husband had kind of like been
incognito for like two years and so they
have this dinner party at their house
and they invite him and his new
girlfriend and like some of their other
friends like to kind of reconnect and
[ __ ] and as the night goes on like [ __ ]
just gets creepier and creepier and
creepier and weirder and weirder and
weirder and you're not really exactly
sure where it's going and also you're
not exactly sure if their protagonist
who was like the ex-husband of the woman
if he's just like imagining stuff
because some stuff that he suspects or
like he thinks is happening is not
happening but then like seriously the I
the whole time I was watching this movie
I was just like on literally on the edge
of my seat you know what I mean I was
just like the whole time and then like
the last third movie it's just it just
goes [ __ ] crazy and then like the
last scene of it and if you know you
know what I'm talking about if you've
seen it the last scene of it my literate
literally my mouth fell open I don't
think I saw it I don't think you did
either I think I watched it in here like
one day yeah in my office but there's a
little it's really really good like I
said it's probably more a thriller than
a horror movie I guess but it's like a
suspense type move like a dinner-party
type movie but yeah really really really
good I recommend that one to everybody
if you like
kind of creature horror like realistic
type of horror I would recommend
backcountry which is based on a true
story about a couple who go hiking in
the woods get lost
like on off of the trail or whatever and
get stalked and attacked by a bear
it doesn't sound all that exciting but
it's really really scary it's really
scary
and like the gore is incredible like it
looks [ __ ] real and it's really yeah
right I don't I can't remember like
where the real story took place but it's
I'm you know I'm sure it's dramatized
for the movie but it's based on like a
true thing that happened like people
they they wandered off the trail because
the dude of course like thought he knew
where he was going and he oh I was here
a long time ago I don't need a map I
don't need a compass bla bla bla and
they end up getting lost inevitably and
you know and then a bear starts coming
after them so yeah it's a very simple
very primal premise but it's really like
super scary now if you like super
arthouse type of stuff then you should
watch the eyes of my mother this is a
black and white movie but it's new but
it's a black and white movie and it's
basically like a three like a three acts
like character study about this woman
who's kind of a psychopath
but also kind of sympathetic as well
it's very Lin Chi and it's very
nightmarish disturbing but if you like
ingmar bergman esque like i said if you
like the lighthouse you would probably
like this as well it's a very similar
kind of tone also there's a movie on
there and I see this one recommended a
lot too and I really liked it it's
called
under the shadow it's kind of like an
Iranian take on the babadook if that
makes any sense yeah it's basically it
takes place in Iran during the 80s
during the iran-iraq war and the main
character is this woman who's she's a
very modern woman but you know when the
you know when the Shah is like you know
when when the Islamic think of all you
know all the religious crackdown and
everything like that they're making all
the women wear headscarves and right
that's that's what's wrong yeah when
that starts to happen
she starts getting like more more
resentful and stuff like a bomb hits her
building but it doesn't explode but it's
like so everyone's leaving like
everyone's fleeing the city so she's
stuck in this building by herself with
her daughter and they start to get
haunted by what is Percival a Djinn yeah
you know what I mean like she doesn't
believe in it but it's just kind of like
this wood it's like it's one of those
movies where it's like scary on its own
but much like the babadook you could
also read it like like a symbolic type
of thing you know what I mean
but yeah it's really really good but
Baca and vari I think he directed it
who's British but he was born around her
his parents are Iranian or something
like that if you like Persepolis you
would probably like this as well it's
kind of a similar vibe also Asian horror
shudder if you haven't seen that not
shudder like you know like the streaming
service but shudder like a camera
shutter that's kind of a well-known one
the autopsy of Jane Doe another one
where you don't really need much of a
cast or much of a you know scope of
location this basically takes place
entirely in a morgue but it goes in like
weird directions that like you don't
expect like this body comes in and they
can't really figure out how she died you
know what I mean and then like the
mystery like deepens from there but it's
like really good it's like a really
nail-biting like suspenseful movie
another found footage one that is really
good as above so below we just watched
this one the other day it's uh it's
actually takes place in the Paris
catacombs and it also has an alchemy
sort of angle which a lot of movies
don't have they should do more of that
actually you know what I mean because
it's like you know the the woman at the
head of it she's kind of like her dad
was like a famous explorer archaeologist
or something and she's looking for the
Philosopher's Stone and they think they
know where it is and it's like supposed
to be like in this secret chamber like
in the Paris catacombs or something so
she gets like a bunch of people to go
down there and look for it and so you
get the whole claustrophobia thing like
the descent but then there's like all
kind of like weird it's basically like
an alchemical
kind of journey into hell and back again
and [ __ ] like that it's very there's a
lot of symbolism and that one too so
that was also very good and the last one
I'm gonna recommend is again if you like
slow burn type stuff ghost stories like
old school type ghost stories
I am the pretty thing that lives in the
house which is basically like a two or
three layered ghost story about a girl
who is she's like a live-in nurse and
she goes to take care of this woman who
has Alzheimer's who was like a um
she wrote like mystery novels like ghost
stories and stuff and now she has
Alzheimer's disease so this nurse comes
to take care of her in her creepy old
house and either the house is haunted or
the main their the nurse as a ghost and
is dead the whole time or there's just
like all this really weird like [ __ ]
going on and you're not really sure
what's going on but the cool thing about
this one is that I love the way they
shot the house we're even even it's just
somebody like sitting in a room and it's
just like the back of their head or
something the way they shot it is like
super super creepy because you're always
like looking in the corners like
thinking there's gonna be creepy [ __ ]
like you
it just has like a really good like a
really claustrophobic like a dread type
of thing like infusing like the whole
movie but yeah really really good like I
said it's it's very sits a very slow
burn very it's not like jump scares like
jumping on your face or nothing like
that but if you really like kind of
old-school ghost stories and like
there's kind of symbolic ghosts or you
should probably be into that
alright so later on I will do to be
recommendations because there's a lot of
good horror movies on to be a lot of
shitty ones too there's a lot of good
old ones but I'm not really gonna
recommend those because we usually get
around to doing retrospectives on older
movies so you know I'm just doing lunch
in the last few years that people might
not have seen but now we are going to
get to finally some stories that licit
er sent it I love a [ __ ] ton but you
know what I mean some people did send
them and like I said if people sent more
than one I'm just gonna read the shorter
one because I don't want this show to be
like 6 hours long because it's already
gonna be long so the first one we're
going to that I'm going to read is
a true story this was submitted by
someone named Johnny eponymous okay so
here we go
I lived in a haunted dorm at Emerson
College in my freshman and sophomore
years it used to be the Charles gate
hotel which was built in 1901 and
apparently was something of a speakeasy
in the 1920s the hotel was kind of an
ad-hoc creation with floors not entirely
matching up so they were springy and you
could hear if someone else was walking
there you now apparently there were
suicides in the hotel in the early
1900's an elevator crash in the 1930s
and since it had served as a dorm for
Boston University in the 1960s probably
the site of a good many heavy bad acid
trips there were many stories of people
seeing ghosts and stuff in their rooms
but most of these were easy to dismiss
and I almost always did until it kind of
happened to me now see this was
something right here that I could relate
to says it was a Sunday night and I was
walking to the common room to watch 120
minutes on MTV which is what I used to
join every Sunday night as well I lived
on the other side of the dorm so I had a
long walk I started walking down to the
common room and I could hear someone
walking just a few feet behind me I
stopped after a little bit and the steps
continued for a few seconds and then
stopped I started walking and after a
few seconds the steps behind me started
up again as if it was waiting for me to
pass by I stopped again and it kept
going a little bit until it sounded like
it was walking right next to me I
started after a second it started after
four or five times doing this I
literally began running and when I got
there I jumped into the common room and
then he says I'm a big guy I don't jump
[Laughter]
after I crashed into the common room I
could hear the footsteps continue down
the hall past the common room no one
else was in there watching the TV yet so
I settled in and started watching Matt
Pinfield who was the guy that used to
host hundred twenty minutes gushing over
the Afghan Whigs about ten minutes later
the girl I had a massive crush on walked
in looking seriously freaked out and
said someone's been following me up and
down the hall and jumped into my arms a
few months later shortly before move out
week I was sitting in the same common
room reading a pile of comics and
watching liquid television and there was
a smell of pipe smoke which isn't
shocking but then there was
literal pipe smoke drifting in from the
hall I followed the trail and found
where it was coming from which was a
little alcove that was completely empty
the smoke was just rising out of nothing
a friend who was walking by said in
passing yeah that always happens at
about 3:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. that's like
the hour of the wolf isn't it
coordinating our Berkman that's like
when all the creepy [ __ ] happens yeah I
still think like sounds like a residual
haunting it does yeah like with the
footsteps and [ __ ] like that
young said they existed yeah well young
said there's a couple cons a couple some
of them are psychic projections of you
yeah it should be kind of like a damn
poltergeist yes other ones were kind of
like residual hauntings things that were
left over in the past yeah and try to
remember the other one that he said I
can't remember right now but there was
supposed there was about three or four I
think he said different types it wants
remember there was that theory I don't
know if it has much credence anymore
nowadays like in paranormal Sarkar's
circles but remember they called it like
the stone tape theory where they were
like like if bad [ __ ] happened in a
location it's almost like the stone or
the walls could like act like a
recording device and it was kind of like
that would be a residual haunting that
yeah that's what I'm saying they
actually made a um they made a British
movie yeah
called the stone tape actually that it
might have been named after that because
I don't think you ought it was that it
was there as an entity it was just
echoes from the past yeah you know place
memories but yeah that it sent that
sounds more plausible to me than like an
actual ghost that you like knows stuff
you know what I mean yeah you go into
that area and somehow your unconscious
your unconscious mind accesses it and
kind of plays it back like a recorder
yeah and that you you're your
unconscious mind is actually bringing it
back into existence or a certain aspect
of something bringing it just like I was
shining where you know Halloran tells ya
Labor's toast yeah you know it leaves a
trace behind
talking about and evidently the Youngs
Redbook is sitting there in Halloran was
a almonds and almonds office sitting on
his front desk which that that book is
about that well like I said I just said
what and I might have mentioned this on
the first you know the first segment of
the show but I just I watched a Jungian
a video that was like a yummy and
interpretation of the shining and they
mentioned that that there's something
that what looked like Young's red book
was sitting in almonds office like on
top of the thing yeah and then they went
on to give like it was like thirty forty
minute video where they wanted to give
like a yes on a young in young and
interpretation yeah at the shining which
I thought was very interesting
her on the show that that explains some
of the stuff from man without in
poltergeist yeah it also links up with
Stuart Hameroff quantum consciousness
theory yeah yeah yeah and that's you
won't know until our tech not until our
technology advances to a certain point
to where we can find out you know what I
mean where we go after we die are their
souls what is a mind yeah where where's
your consciousness actually located you
know that kind of stuff because you know
Hameroff knows a lot about the brain and
he's saying that your consciousness is
not just a bunch of neurons firing and
making computations there's more to it
than that
yeah it's an analog system and it's got
to be have something do the quantum some
kind of a quantum process quantum
computation process which is and you
know it's an analog process and it may
be happening in a different dimension to
yeah we are thinking in terms of just
three dimensions it's three spatial yeah
there might be all kind of [ __ ] going on
way in but because you know according
like theoretically there's other
dimensions all over them yeah so your
consciousness probably in a higher
dimensions slightly outside of
space-time type of deal and if that's
the case then that means a lot of weird
stuff is going to be plausible or
plausible if possible yeah but the cops
in other words the cops this could have
have access to things outside the normal
time stream yeah I mean you know that's
a really interesting field of research
and I'm kind of like curious to see if
anything comes out of that it's UFO
technology yeah when you can start
making
[Laughter]
it's super high technology we don't get
it yet
all right so this is another true
anecdote this was sent to me by Sharon
and Jerry O'Neill now they say hi Jenny
and Tom from the northeast of Scotland
how you doing hi there we love watching
your show and wanted to tell you about
something which happened to us just hope
it's good enough to make it onto your
Halloween special we watched several
nights a week watch all the old ones too
with a shout of stick of 13 on 13 okay I
do that was like some other channels
like [ __ ] k cinema and yeah and oliver
heartburn stuff I'm just like stick out
of [ __ ] case yeah
keep up the good work and enjoy our
story which is a hundred percent true
not long after my husband and I first
got together in 2007 I found out a
friend of mine was terminally ill the
two of us drove the near 160 miles in my
car to see my friend which sadly turned
out to be the last time I would ever see
him the trip took us from Inverness and
the Highlands of Scotland to Fife which
on the map is a little bit across from n
borough that sticks out like a little
dog's head the drive is a pleasant one
through mountains and the type of
scenery so often used in films to depict
the nicer aspects of Scotland I won't go
into detail about the actual visit
suffice to state to say bidding a final
farewell is not a pleasant experience
but I'm glad we had the chance
we stayed from the Friday to the Sunday
and soon it was time to pack our stuff
and begin the three-hour trip back home
this might sound like a long drive but
many parts of the infamous a nine Road
is still single lane despite being the
main road through this part of the
country with a maximum 60 mile per hour
speed limit imposed it is therefore the
main road used by lorries or trucks for
you Americans for transporting goods
around the country so you were often
stuck behind a slower vehicle this
didn't bother us on this occasion as we
weren't in a hurry as the time passed I
was aware we were approaching the last
public toilet stop available called
Ralia before we reached home it was a
dark and cold November night so I took a
slight detour to visit the facilities
and stretch our legs to get to the
isolated toilet block drivers need to
turn off the main road taking a small
lane to the left which drops down
slightly from the height of the main
road above there are no street lights
along this part so you need
lights on full beam approaching the
building which has a cafe upstairs
during the day with a tourist
information center underneath and a
large clean toilet block around the back
I pointed out the first parking area to
my boyfriend telling him that's four
lorries and tourist coaches the carpark
we needed was at the front of the
building so I drove around having made
this trip many times on my own in the
past
I knew the layout well on approaching
the carpark we saw a lorry parked across
several of the car spaces but no other
vehicles we thought it was strange since
the parking area for lorries was that
the other end has already described but
we didn't give it much more thought we
parked the car and got out my boyfriend
was alarmed to see just how secluded
this place was from the carpark we could
see the large building which is busy and
welcoming in the daylight but silent and
dark while we stood there adjusting our
eyes to the little light available we
could hear cars on the road above but
not many as it was getting late due to
the high banks however which were
covered with trees bushes and grass the
road couldn't be seen from the carpark
and drivers going past would be
oblivious to what was going on down here
after using the facilities we walked
past the lorry assuming the driver was
sleeping we were wrong
we sat in the car with the engine
running for a few minutes to get a smoke
and get some heat I initially put the
headlights on but my boyfriend told me
to switch them off as the lorry was
behind us and he wanted to be able to
keep an eye on our total surroundings
just to be sure I immediately turned off
the lights a minute or so later my
boyfriend saw the lorry drivers door
open which momentarily lit up his cab
then in an instant it went dark again it
was light light long enough however for
my boyfriend to see the man had
something in his hand at this point I
have to confess my uneasiness about
sitting in a dark secluded car park was
turning to heavy anxiety even though
this was something I'd done many times
alone in the past but where did the
driver go he wasn't walking along the
driver side of the lorry and there was
no torchlight beam so he obviously
wasn't fixing a fault had he gone to the
toilets no we would have seen him why
was he not parked in the lorry parking
area at this point I followed my gut
instinct and said to my boyfriend I'm
going to keep the lights off but I'm
going to move the car over to the other
side of the carpark neared the exit we
were still warming up and weren't quite
ready to continue our final leg of the
journey so I quietly and slowly drove
the car over to the other side but as I
stopped I didn't
a handbrake on suddenly my boyfriend
shouts what the hell hit the lights now
I turned the lights on full and we
looked over to our car had been parked
only moments earlier there standing with
a startled look on his face was a
moustached man wearing glasses and
holding a tire wrench in his hand at
shoulder height clearly he wasn't
changing a tire and hadn't noticed we
had moved the car he looked over in an
instant but before he had a chance to
run at us I hit the pedals and got us
the hell out of there we've never
stopped at the rally a facilities since
that day and I can't believe how many
times I had been there alone at night in
the past something I'll never do again
that is it that is like a true version
of like the hook-hand story it's like it
ought to be and it's like you look out
and there's like a guy that's just like
about to [ __ ] beat your [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] scary man yeah wonder
what the motive was was he was he uh
just like were they driving behind him
no they pulled into a like a rest area
yeah and she said it was weird because
like that wasn't because you know like
we have the breast areas to where it's
like you know the big ones have like you
know the semi trucks in one area and
then like regular cars in the other
areas she said and then this one's like
that too but so this car was like they
note the truck they noticed it because
it was parked in the car area instead of
in the semi truck area so they thought
it was weird and there was no other cars
at the car park so this just like in
just like in the United States some of
these truck drivers are killers I guess
you just gotta watch out we pack Heat
over here it's weird because I was just
reading um I was reading this other
woman's account it's a this kind of [ __ ]
fascinates me and I guess there's like a
whole reddit subreddit about this about
like Close Encounters like with
murderers like later you find out that
someone got murdered like in the same
place you rat or whatever and I was
reading one about this one woman and she
said you know we have this park like
near our house and I you know I she
watched her baby like in a stroller all
the time like in broad daylight
she's like so I was walking in there one
day and she's like I started getting
these really creepy feeling and like I
look over and I see this like really
really skeevy sketchy like old guy like
kind of like
king-like by the path like in the bushes
bushes kind of and she's like he needs
kind of looking at me and it was kind of
freaking me out so she like took her
phone out it's like I said it's broad
daylight she takes her phone out and
starts talking to the phone like really
loudly like oh hi honey yeah manages oh
it's starting to rain him but because so
she like turned around and like scooted
like right the [ __ ] out of there and
then a couple days later somebody got
murdered in that Park Wow so who's that
guy go yeah but it just it seems a
little yeah you know what I mean I'm
just saying that's pretty creepy that's
what I'm saying that's we're gonna kind
of [ __ ] fascinates but I guess it
fascinates other people too because
there's no like I said there's a whole
subreddit about that where because
remember I can't remember what show we
were talking about it but ones where
what like what about people that got
like picked up as hitchhikers by like
Ted Bundy and did it get killed and then
like later on you found out that that
was Ted Bundy that picked you up yeah
holy [ __ ] I was I don't I don't think I
never like want to go outside after that
same for me as a guy cuz you know I know
these guys are you know I'd [ __ ] those
dudes up well yeah but it's like you
know like I said it's not it was only a
couple of them that were physically
imposing compared to me you know that
big old dude and that big old dude whose
mama he is mama dead camper at camper
yeah I wouldn't want to tangle with him
he was like what he was like twice my
height six foot six or something taller
than that I think it was like six nine
times yeah he was a monster yeah he was
like a really really don't know that's
really the only one that I can think of
that was physically imposing in any way
and he was like that happened like
that's who I was trying to think of too
at kemper because he picked up
hitchhikers yeah also and he let a lot
of them go so that's gonna be like
something cuz you would remember that
guy like this big [ __ ] six foot tall
think about it giant Kimber was kind of
mild-mannered and real submissive his
personality yeah you first like
evidently when you first met him yeah he
seemed like he'd be a big [ __ ] can you
kill you well that's what I mean it's
appearances can be deceiving that's why
you can never like never be like I was
just some [ __ ] or whatever like that
because then yeah because a lot of
serial killers come across like that
yeah until they [ __ ] stab you in the
face yeah
oh the clown what's his name Casey Casey
yeah Johnny I guess had fun Casey up
[ __ ] oh pretty boy
hey what Ted Bundy Ted Bundy [ __ ] Ted
Bundy's dead he'd probably be pretty
easy to [ __ ] him up nowadays
he's probably just ashes somewhere the
only ones ever probably [ __ ] about the
only one that I think that my dad that
would worry me a lot was Charles Ning
and yang and Leonard Blake yeah they
showed up with suppressed Mac tens and
full auto weapons yeah stuff they had
military training and they just went
straight to guns yeah
so they were a [ __ ] threat huge
threat to they knew what they were doing
yeah but most of them were just weasels
yeah you know weasels running out
picking up hookers and strangling them
that's that's the maid that was the main
one yeah
that Oh dick head-to-head in England him
and his him and his wife killing those
tenants that guy he was to Fred and
rosemary West yeah they're pretty bad
yeah the freakiest man weirdos
yeah yeah freakiest family that was
pretty fair game
hey I probably want to tango that dude
I'm not sure how exactly how big he was
I really like he was pretty meaty yeah
yeah but you know it's just the way they
are I guess you know yeah like I said
you can't just they're not all the same
like across the board like some of them
er yeah big hulking brute swell it's it
you know I just feel like you're most
[ __ ] up serial killers are usually
just kind of like we deal is errs being
losers because why would you have to be
a serial killer if you were actually
like and they kind of get you through
stealth and then picking the weak they
choose me yeah targets you know yeah
that's true that other dude who was
tying them boys to the board and using
the damn glass that guy yeah he was a
shipper yeah well [ __ ] his that his own
legend a sidekick hit killed him yeah
pretty much all right
so let's do another true story this one
was sent to me by Victoria Barnett
this is a true story that happened in
Washington State in an area north of
Seattle that used to be thick woods and
swamps before it was developed in the
1970s
my parents bought a house in the late
90s when I was seven and when the sale
was finalized the former owner sent us a
letter apologizing for the crazy
next-door neighbor more about him later
kids giving me watch her my it's alright
the house immediately had a really
creepy vibe and I wasn't comfortable
being alone there I felt like something
was watching me all the time things
intensified when I was a teenager I've
read about other hauntings and it seems
like there's something about teenage
girls that attract spirits and
especially nasty ones where's the story
from again Washington State okay near
Seattle okay glass objects started
shattering randomly people felt the
sensation of being watched much more
intensely including extended family
coming over to visit my aunt and cousins
house at for us house sat for us one
Christmas while we were away and they
said that the house felt really creepy
and they were uncomfortable the whole
time this has already sounded like
poltergeist like mad at mom yeah one of
something haunting to me yeah
one of my cousin's saw a full-body
apparition that responded to her
noticing it it looked like a young man
dressed in modern clothes he walked by
her and looked over when she asked who
are you and then walked around a corner
and vanished
my aunt heard my cousin asking him and
saw her get up to investigate I would
hear footsteps following me home when
I'd walk home from school I was on a
deserted street and would hear someone
walking and stopping when I'd stop but
there was nobody there
the house had very creaky stairs and
floorboards and one time I clearly heard
someone walking upstairs and then into
the kitchen where I was I was gripping a
huge steel knife that my great
grandmother owned in case there was a
real person coming to get me and I told
it to [ __ ] off when I realized it was
the spirit and it worked temporal
temporarily my great-grandmother was a
fiery Texan woman who gave zero [ __ ]
she chased off a vacuum cleaner salesman
with a shotgun when she was a little old
[Laughter]
yeah my grandfather my grandfather on my
mother's side my grandfather's brother
was named Ted Weems Ted Weems
and we have another on him which one was
Ted the heiress many different brothers
I'll remember which Weems it was which
we yeah Ronnie yes it is Rob who's
Ronnie tan - Charlie Ronnie Ronnie was a
president of Electrolux vacuum cleaners
throughout the 60s and the 70s became a
multi-millionaire and hit the California
state lottery and then the largest slot
machine jackpot in Las Vegas our
memories on the same week that's right
and bought a huge mansion up in
California all that [ __ ] was crooked he
was a gangster yeah he was a gangster
they're all dead now his friend was in
the damn California gaming committee and
when he's gaining commissions yeah yeah
yeah they're all [ __ ] mafia yeah and
my I guess you called my great-great
uncle your grandfather's brothers your
great-uncle I guess yeah
my great-uncle bill electrolux and he
ran electrolux into the ground with that
[ __ ] silver tongue of his but I
worked for it for a couple years and
[ __ ] made good money that's gangster
ass job [ __ ] telemarketers working
for me getting in there were carpet
cleaning services and [ __ ] you know this
is after I got out of the Army the first
couple years got out of the army I loved
it matter of fact I got an Electrolux
right there it's not the same company
anymore though it went bankrupt yes and
it was really theirs because Ronnie
robbed that company blind through the
back channels yeah he built it but then
he robbed it yeah yeah he's a crook he's
correct
he was cool though yeah he's very cool
but uh but he lost half of his tongue
and part of his job to cancer it was
because [ __ ] he was talking
[Laughter]
yeah ended up talking like that for the
rest of his life man and then when I
joined the company everybody knew Ronnie
you know so I rolled in there with a
gangster ass [ __ ] presentation you
know and yeah and I was champion
salesman and [ __ ] in the Northeast and
in my sales territory as Wellesley
Massachusetts yeah yeah Wellesley Weston
Newton in Dover the [ __ ] richest
richest neighborhoods outside Boston
yeah yeah they're all that big money was
I put central systems in there and
everything this is before another [ __ ]
that happened but you know cuz I got
started to go back and Dec as you say I
visually drifted back into the military
industrial complex I didn't really cut
it I wasn't really a good civilian I
tended to kind of get in trouble as a
civilian I had to be I had to be kind of
like kept under [ __ ] I hope you can't
Center [ __ ] you know military type
conditions some exciting to do but no
yeah she ran that salesman off his
tongue was a silver enough I guess yeah
well see that's what because I mean she
pointed that out to say that like she
likes having the night he was a look
that's a loser says when you're never
supposed to talk your way into
somebody's house you always have to have
them invite you in like a vampire that's
why the services were for telemarketers
and carpet cleaning services and you
know and once I was in there then a demo
would start the thing is out whatever I
did I did it for the good of the
customer they always needed the product
and they couldn't afford a new one I had
used what's that out of me I've made a
lot of money on used woods called Bojack
and we weren't really supposed to do it
but everybody in the company did it
taking old trade ins and reconditioning
them and if you couldn't sell them a new
one in the emergency you'd always have
like a couple of used ones in the
backyard yeah and you know but the thing
is is that the managers above you in
this damn power structure they wanted
those because that's what they were
making their money off of yeah all those
damn trade is that [ __ ] it but yeah so
that's I mean but she was pointing out
that this that her great-grandma had
like run the vacuum cleaner salesman off
yeah yes I'm saying it's like you know
that's what she was
badass so that's why she likes like
getting her knife because she yeah she
was getting like badass vibes yeah
electrolux tales I know that was just
another era so the great grandmother
it's like her son my grandfather the
teller of the story has some psychic
abilities I have another ancestor on my
dad's side who was an exorcist and a
pagan warlock
if sensitivity to the paranormal is
hereditary I certainly have the pedigree
for that I don't see ghosts with my
physical eyes but I can sense them and
they do appear to me in dreams now for
the really creepy [ __ ] I had been
tormented late at night for a long time
before this happened
I'd sense two male spirits and they'd
whisper constantly I'd feel them
hovering over me in bed one night I
rolled over to ignore it but then I felt
a big finger poked my eye it couldn't
have been me because my hands were under
my cheek and I have smaller fingers with
long nails and this finger didn't have a
nail that poked me it just felt like
skin if I freaked the [ __ ] out and saged
the whole house in the wee hours of the
morning which would tone it down for a
bit I had also gotten pushed over when I
was getting up one morning I felt the
first push and was able to grab a
bookshelf so I didn't fall but then I
got pushed again and fell a bit causing
a commotion my mom got up none of this
was ever sleep paralysis because I was
always able to get up and run to my
mom's room when I got too scared
shortly after this I had a nightmare
where a man with a horrifying half
rotted face was taunting me and laughing
at me it was angry and full of hatred to
in a deep sleep I felt my face contort
in pure fear and my brain screamed at
screamed at me to wake up I was able to
wake myself up and didn't sleep for the
rest of the night by this point I
thought I was crazy and having all these
experiences and it seemed like nobody
else was but we just weren't telling
each other what was happening I kept it
to myself like everything else a while
later I had a sleepover with a few
friends
one of my friends lived across the
street and invited her boyfriend over
ugh I like that so when the rest of us
fell asleep they went back to her place
for some privacy
my best friend who had been on the floor
decided to get in bed with me she saw a
half rotten man's face on the pillow
next to me and it looked angry she noped
out of that and stayed on the floor you
know understandably I was horrified when
she told
what she saw and I told her that I'd
seen it too just in my dreams instead
she recently told her husband that story
he shocked us by saying that he had
experienced something similar with a
half rotten man's face that was awful
and made you feel absolute fear he grew
up pretty close to where we had lived as
well we might have had some kind of it
situation happening here
strangely I've tried telling multiple
people this story said they can make a
youtube video or whatever about it and
something always happened so the story
is never read I wonder if it tries to
suppress the story somehow so it doesn't
get exposed who wouldn't it be creepy if
like I'm reading this and then when I go
back to edit it like the sound guys edit
this boy I wet my pants and seriously
she says I moved out of that house and
away from that neighborhood and my
depression went away immediately I
noticed that when people moved to the
neighborhood they went from being quite
normal to becoming addicts divorcing
their spouse losing their job and
finances and other awful things here's
where the weird neighbor comes in he's
the oddest most hateful person I've ever
met his whole family is strange and
miserable I used to be friends with his
son and he said he had never seen his
father smile I think that when he dies
whatever hateful spirit is there will
absorb him and get stronger the area is
just weird and seems to SAP people of
the good within them some people get
strangely obsessed with their house
around there - my dad was one of them
the house eventually got foreclosed in
the recession and my dad squatted there
for a while refusing to leave until he
was forced to the weird neighbor was
oddly obsessed with us and the house as
well like I said watch our situation he
didn't like it when we tried to make
improvements or plant anything I think
the area is cursed or something and that
people shouldn't live there mm-hmm bad
house it is yeah that's kind of giving
me a little bit of the [ __ ] like the
Keith lender yeah that's because that
was kind of weird to where it's like
that wasn't that was near Seattle - it
wouldn't he haven't read my story with
math Mountain poltergeist you should
good you should read it there are some
parallels my situation was a little bit
different wasn't very visual we didn't
really seen the apparitions aside like
some blue haze looking stuff yeah that's
that's about it but yeah yeah it's good
story that is a very good story that
it's like creepy as [ __ ] and like I said
I will freak the [ __ ] out if you know
what at that point
so tom has decided that he needs a buddy
for this portion of the show yeah so
that's gonna be like his little buddy in
case he gets scared or something yeah I
guess I had one of these when I was a
little kid yeah I bye I got two of them
now this one in another one and I had a
dragon I didn't have and then I had
combat lurvy that one was never brought
to the United States
I didn't I need to get a reading this is
yeah you guys would know him as a Shogun
warrior but in Japan never known as a
jumbo machine derp
which is much cooler name but in Miami a
lot more they were a lot better yeah
yeah I love these things he can shoot
missiles out of his hand Kenny yeah in
the Japanese version in the Japanese
version didn't come with us it just came
with a regular hand this is an accessory
that you could buy okay the missiles are
and they could win on any robot of this
brand but for play purposes you know in
the United States they they would give
certain [ __ ] off as like accessories
just like that Godzilla that you could
shoot as fish inexplicably and in the
Japanese version he also had wings yeah
yeah well it's called a jet scrander
which is big jet wings but the American
version didn't come with that oh well
yeah there was a lot of money though now
yeah he can hang out what you hear now
me I'm a little buddy - yeah like I have
a little Halloween buddy in case you
yeah big spider spider I didn't even see
I don't even like me to buy Halloween
decorations because mental office is
already Halloween decorated I just had
to move the chairs pretty much yeah so I
remember when I was only a little bit
bigger than this yeah yeah that's
because you know these come out 77 I
think that is like a little time and is
my robot buddy yeah I'm a little bit
bigger than like walking down the street
together yeah a bit on your big wheel
this is about
I was only twice the size of this yeah
if you look so cute like yeah
alright so our next true account comes
from John Hufnagel now he actually sent
me this
less than 24 hours after the [ __ ]
actually happened right so here's like
the setup he says I work on it so I
usually am up at night and around the
middle of my shift around 3:00 a.m. as
when we do most audit papers so my mind
is always on that stuff on my two days
off I'm usually killing time on my
computer at night as I sleep mornings
lately I've been spending time with a
good friend and tend to adjust my sleep
a bit to daytime and back again over the
last few weekends I've slept at my
friend's house on his couch last week I
had a ton of overtime and was working
two 16-hour days while sleeping at a
hotel I work at to help me cover shifts
I don't know how people do that kind of
[ __ ] man I would just be like a zombie
all the time my sleep can be hard in an
odd environment that isn't my own bed
this week I kept sleeping four or so
hours or for my timelessly first sleep
was limited as a result I got to the
weekend with probably 16 lost hours of
sleep so my mind is a bit stretched thin
and exhausted which is a factor going
forward so I spent yesterday Friday
October 18th finishing up work and
instead of going home for a nap I was
oddly wide-awake so since my friend was
up I went home grabbed some things and
headed over to hang out I expected I
would take a midday nap but it never
happened we planned a crustle marathon
he's like thanks for that delightful
Kurt nickname by the way it's now
immortal and will never die welcome to
the you're being like absorbed into the
collective watching crustle movies okay
they naturally increase the man's
testosterone oh you don't need drugs you
don't need any of that [ __ ] after it was
like I'd be curious to know what what
crustle marathon what York Russell
marathon consisted of so let me know in
the comments what me
well what would yours what would yours
be escape from New York's game LA the
king um Christmas Chronicles be on there
soldier bone tomahawk yeah
big trouble little China yeah all good
choices what's the one the dark blue
line
no of the [ __ ] the one where he played
the bet the bad cop yeah yeah yeah blue
line or blue some dark blue blue blue
it's not one of my favorites but it was
a pretty good one the main ones was
escape from New York saying yeah I feel
like any self-respecting crime yeah it
has to have those movies involved yeah
but he was in like a [ __ ] ton of me and
actually you know I'm gonna go ahead and
put in [ __ ] once upon a time in
Hollywood now yeah he did some voiceover
and did a couple scenes in that one also
I guess you moved I guess you could put
in death proof that was the Quentin
Tarantino Roberts remember it was
grindhouse it was like two parts
I didn't see that one I don't think yeah
you did i disremember the first half of
it was like Rose McGowan with the with
the gun leg and in the second half his
Kurt Russell he was like a stunt man
yeah I fell asleep during down when I
had to go back and look at that one
again I like that actually like that
soldier is definitely one of my cure
across a movie also Stargate oh that's
right at first Stargate that was given
to me I got to get that on blu-ray yeah
I like that was it James Spader's in it
oh yeah okay so Kurosawa Marathon we're
setting the scene yeah after a few
movies we realized it was about 11:20
p.m. my friend was a little drunk and
actually wanted to continue movies and
beer which you know fair enough
I was so stretched thin that I'm amazed
that I attempted another movie for a
moment it felt possible but thirty
minutes in and I was nodding off so we
paused the movie and planned for sleep
it didn't take me long to fall asleep I
think even though I was well beyond the
point of sleep deprived second wind
soon after this a truly creepy and
unsettling thing happened now I must
tell you that I occasionally suffer from
exploding head syndrome which I had
heard of actually for those listeners
who don't know what that is it's
essentially the same thing as a
hallucination only with audio not visual
information it has happened before my
past but I think I didn't remember or
register it much in recent years
especially after ten years of working
11:00 p.m. to 7:00 a.m. I tend to get
tired mid shift or at home when laying
on the couch watching shows I start to
nod off and if I actually do lose
semi-consciousness I will real way
in two to thirty minutes later that
might have been 20 to 30 minutes I'm not
sure and here an odd sound EHS for me
sounds like a shallow sigh or exhale
with a voice like tone I hear this a few
times a month and it's rather scientific
and normal but it did freak me out a bit
before I realized what it actually was
first I dismissed it as happening then
when I thought deeper I would ignore and
forget it
eventually it happened frequently enough
that I took notice and it actually at
times freaked me out a little I feared
it was a person in the room with me I
thought at times is my work haunted but
when EHS happens at times at home I
don't want to be creeped out and think
my apartment is haunted but no it's just
my brain playing audio tricks on me when
waking back up from light sleeps I've
always been a believer in various of
various sorts but I also have a
completely scientific mind that battles
logic with beliefs or faiths that lack
proof or explanation this is also spoken
as someone who has lost a few loved ones
I need to believe in good things
existing but I think I've always feared
bad things and sensed them the way you
sense eyes on you sometimes or times
when you're alone and suddenly switch
from content to completely freaked out
like someone is in the house the
scientist in me says these feelings are
just old leftover primal prey instincts
to avoid being hunted there are times
I've been asleep with someone else in
another room who wakes up and walks
around and I sleep through it but if I
hear footsteps are simply sent someone
is moving towards me I wake up and
sometimes even get scared for a second
yes it's just another evolutionary prey
Drive but still it's almost like a sixth
sense or the brain is still taking an
audio input to help survive being preyed
on in sleep mode so all that aside I do
believe in evil things but I also
believe in good things then when
something truly eerie occurs all you can
think of is dread and the bad things and
it's hard to find comfort in those
moments of fear this is some this
somewhat reminds me of Tom being awoken
as a child to the weird blooping sound
like a water jug air bubble before being
bombarded by flying socks and closed by
the poltergeist didn't quite happen that
way though yeah well it was similarly
yeah last night about 21 hours ago now
like I said this from when he said it to
me I'm sound asleep when three loud and
fast knocks wake me up it was rapid if
you count seconds 1 2 3 it was like
adding in a 1.5 so speeding up the
counting by about double to count three
times in one second of time
tap-tap-tap ten seconds later I was
waking up slowly and was confused by
what I heard who was knocking by 20
seconds I realized it was not my friend
I could hear him snoring the next room
over I started wondering if I imagined
it as another EHS noise the taps were so
distinctive they seemed loud but
apparently didn't wake up my friend so
maybe not even real sounds by 30 seconds
I'm actively trying to rationalize if I
heard knocks or not and swiftly the fear
that it was real and disembodied was
starting to invade my mind I suddenly
remembered that three knocks is widely
thought of as a mocking of the Holy
Trinity yeah that they usually say they
don't like demonic possessions and stuff
like yes everything is three yeah it was
going as funny as it was cool it was
like that during Mammoth Mountain -
three scratches on the door like a claws
yeah three drops of blood on the damn
toilet paper yes three but but I have a
different theory of it yeah yeah I I
knew about the Holy Trinity when I was a
kid so if it was something from the
unconscious maybe maybe that's what it
was manifest but I also looked at it
this way if you had one scratch on a
door it wouldn't mean much if he had to
it wouldn't mean much but if you had
three it would look like a car then it
looks deliberate it looks more
deliberate it's the least amount this
yeah it's like the minimum amount for is
kind of like overkill so it's more
efficient I think for the phenomenon to
go well I'll just make three it's more
energy if it happened fast yeah you're
trying to get a message across from
young is unconscious maybe you know
Matthew because like if it was just one
scratch you probably won't even know you
can blow it off because a neck was that
thing there's no you can't really it
doesn't look like an entity did it yeah
it doesn't look like anyone said or a
being or a monster did it but there's
three at least you know whether it's
talking about it as a claw yeah and then
for some reason there were three drops
of blood maybe because it just makes it
look a look it's the minimum amount that
looks deliberate yeah one or two might
be ignored
yeah or interpreted as something else
but if there's three of them then it's
got an area for it explain that away
sure right if there's four drops on
there you don't really need the fourth
one cuz the three was enough so because
then I
feel like most and maybe that's like a
primal thing with humans because you
know like animals that have like you
know that number of claws are like it
just looks like that number of claws you
know what I mean yeah like a big pattern
could also have something to do with
like the triangle a triangle has three
angles to it or three sides to it it's
it's very strong and it's the minimum
amount of angles you need to make a
three-dimensional object yeah so it
might just be something that the
unconscious or some that the others
might just be kind of like the default
thing that the unconscious goes to yeah
three yeah because it's more than two
there just seems to be like a lot of
like superstitions about the number
three and maybe for that very reason
like you have like across the globe like
in all different cultures yeah so I
think that's maybe why so I don't
necessarily think it has much to do with
Christianity it might be like it could
be that the Christians did the exact
same thing they just kind of gravitated
towards the number three because that
was that is significant more significant
more mutually supportive yeah you know
talking about so that's that's yeah I I
think I'm gonna go with you on that one
yes I think it's just kind of like the
unconscious mind kind of just gravitates
a lot towards the number three yeah
because it's a good number for some
reason there's something about the human
mind interprets that is deliberate yeah
but like you said it's the minimum
amount yeah that's it looks like order
yeah that's like I said it's the least
amount that looks like it was done on
purpose
exactly yeah so I think that's what it
is yeah but yeah so what you know like
he was saying there's you know a
paranormal thing that it's like you know
three that's like a mocking of the
Trinity right usually means the devil or
demons apparently there were a few more
superstitions I didn't remember at the
time and it had been less than a minute
since being awoken so only so much time
to think I guess once I was starting to
fathom it could be something bad I was
justifiably creeped the heck out the odd
thing is that I had identified the sound
as distinctively knocking on glass but
like big heavy thick glass the way
knocking on a glass door or window
sounds like
I'm sitting on the third floor of my
friend's condo on a couch my head next
to a big glass window into my left a big
glass balcony door in the next room was
this out of my friend snoring so I found
it hard to believe it was him besides it
still could have been just a
hallucination but had been about fifty
seconds since the rapid knock that awoke
me and I was still trying to rationalize
it a terrifying thought crossed my mind
what if the time is now at this very
moment of the knocking 3:00 a.m. like I
said I was also three yeah that's what I
mean well that's why in a lot of
cultures have that like 3:00 a.m.
there's like that's like when the veil
between the living and the dead is the
thinnest just like you think you know
anyway just like the Halloween the
Celtic thing so that that's a very
common superstition uh you know 3m
witching hour the devil's hour like I
said anymore Bergman even a horror movie
called the hour of the wolf and that's
what was about from 3:00 or 4:00 a.m. um
you know what if the three knocks were a
demon so he's try not to fridge I was
trying not to freak myself out even more
I swear I was looking around a poorly
lit dark room and hoping not to see
movement or eyes or shadow things
however at that moment the most
terrifying concept was my need to know I
needed to know what time it was just to
dismiss it as silly audio hallucination
again I sit up and move forward where I
had left my phone and I checked the time
frigging 301 am a little over one minute
since the three knocks so of course that
had happened at three o'clock in the
morning I wanted to scream suddenly my
worst fear was realized and I would have
been better off not looking at the damn
time for the next ten minutes emits the
sound of muffled snoring through my
friends bedroom door i sat in the living
room petrified about five minutes of
utter dead silence later I slowly lost
my ability to explain it away by science
I started remembering the 3m as the
witching hour but it's not necessarily a
demon thing and I slightly recalled some
other history or superstition involved
I was now reaching out for comfortable
thoughts but I was way too freaked out
to focus my mind and call myself back to
sleep again then my friend snoring stops
he gets up and goes to use the bathroom
did he hear it too and he just took him
longer to get up was it just in my head
he later said he heard nothing at all if
it had been the door then it would be
odd since my friend's condo has a high
balcony on the third floor no way
someone can climb up and enter and the
outside window behind my head opens to
nothing so someone would have had
floating to knock there just like can
say l'm slot man I don't want to scare
you but maybe it was like it was that
glit kid yeah
I'm suddenly reminded of the scene in
Amityville Horror I thought of that as
well in which the father keeps waking up
at the same time every night yeah 3:15
also in the scary concept of demons
floating outside of Windows no thank you
I don't want to see floating or a Judy
eyes I saw that out the window when I
was a kid one time oh my god I've almost
peed my pants and I don't know I still
don't know what it was I was on the
first floor like I woke up and I looked
out the window and there's red eyes out
there yeah like in my what are ya when
was this when I was kid probably settled
was I eight nine maybe wait
and I was like sit and I freaked out I
like what my parents are like my dad
went out there was got everything like
that and see anything hmm [ __ ] red
eyes out there must been sleep maybe and
I had say I think I had seen the
Amityville Horror then and that bad it
really freaks me out so it's like maybe
it had something to do with that but
yeah he says all jokes aside this was
simple but incredibly unsettling do the
confirmation that had been exactly 3:00
a.m. when the knocks occurred that woke
me up whether real or imagined sound was
a moot point it was all made way too
real by the bloody timing and its
association to demons and the mocking of
the Trinity when my friend was up I
couldn't help but tell him because it
could have kept me from sleeping again
if I didn't get it out later upon
curious googling I found that this is a
common occurrence not just the knocking
but the specific 3:00 a.m. event or
experience many thousands of people have
experienced this and while hearing and
seeing things can be explained by sleep
science a perfect 3:00 a.m. wake-up call
is hard to explain away maybe you can
make EHS and three knocks and three a.m.
occurrences in with show topic some day
I think that might be interesting is
exploding head syndrome is a very
interesting topic well like I said I
think the whole three reoccurrence of
three over and over again in the
paranormal I think it's just because
it's the most efficient yeah
that's why maybe well we should look
into that I want to look into like the
superstitions behind three and like
where that might have come true because
I'm really interested in that now it
looks more on purpose yeah three there's
something primal about three yeah and
there's like a lot of creepy [ __ ] around
three and maybe that's why many people
just like wake up at you know at that
time or whatever
so he says now I'm a bit worried but for
new reasons I chose to share this
experience because it just happened less
than 24 hours ago like I said he sent
this to me on October 19th so it's
helping to make that unsettling feeling
leave me I'm looking at the clock now
it's 12:45 a.m. I can't help but worry
if I go to sleep now I'll hear it again
this time alone in my own apartment but
I don't want to just stay up either if
something more occurs I'll update you if
not assume everything is OK the reason
for my concern has shifted from myself
though to loved ones you see upon my
curious research I was reminded that 3
knocks is often associated with death
omens this is eerily similar to my
family story with the drowning of my
cousin and the Belva Trang I now wonder
if it ranked three times or more the
omen states that you or someone you know
or love will die or has died this is
very freaky because an old childhood
friend just died on Wednesday I grew up
around him since day care and he was one
of my first friends and neighbors I
heard from my mom through her
connections to my hometown even though
there's a police investigation and his
name is not yet released publicly he's a
friend who drifted a bit and then lost
touch apparently he worked forestry in
Campbell River British Columbia about a
three hour drive south from our hometown
and 20 minute drive from where my
parents live he was not my best friend
but a friend who often joined us for fun
and games a friend whom I share many
memories with he's often lived in my
memory whenever I review my nostalgic
past and popped up in my fiction writing
as a lot of his inspired by direct
childhood experiences as one of my first
friends ever I guess you could say that
my old friend James has always been
frozen in the history of my memories if
I managed to finish my books and a
character he inspired will remain there
long after I'm gone
granted we would have had no idea what
each other look like as adults or even
know who the people we grew up to become
near strangers in a weird way I guess
but I have no doubt that if we had
reconnected it would be directly through
our past memories so this loss while
small compared to losing my father and
other family in recent years stings a
fair bit nonetheless in a weird way I've
just lost someone I once knew well and
cared about so maybe those three knocks
are for him I'll be it a bit late he
sadly died quite violently targeted and
tragically shot six times my thoughts
all weekend have been on him and trying
to convert the somberness and a peaceful
memorial thinking about the happy
memories and who I knew him wants to be
and keeping that person alive as I
always have in my memories even if he is
now gone forever and we will never get
to meet a second time that what I think
I'm also worried about now is that
someone else may die you can't buy into
superstition too much or you'll become a
wreck
even if three knocks wake me up and it
just so happens to be exactly 3:00 a.m.
which is freaking creepy and potentially
something far worse than a death omen
I've lost enough people though and I
don't want to lose more anytime soon I
think something evil knocking is almost
preferable to another funeral rather
that then rather than that twisted
Soapy's choice
I think I will just try and ignore this
for now I just thought it would make a
good story to share well the details are
fresh and less than a day old he then he
is talking about how um he's like this
letter got a bit long and deeply worded
if you have time to read it feel free to
shorten and paraphrase a little I feel
comfort and sharing it with you too I
thought I would say this because it's
nice but um he says I feel comfort and
sharing it with you to sense you feel
comfortable sharing a wide variety of
things with us listeners on a weekly
basis yes because we drink and we just
like well and plus I'm just like the
kind of person it's just like whatever I
just tell people whatever I have no like
shame we have a nice audience anyway
yeah it's real so if you're listening
then you know what we're talking about
or at least interested in what we're
talking you're not listening and
advocate listen then you didn't even
hear you say so we just say what's on
our minds and say how we feel
yeah and if people who understand what
kind of people who can resonate with a
stick yeah that's all this yeah so
that's it that's the best way to do a
show like this well yeah that's what I
think too there's no reason why you try
to make a show to appeal to a general
audience nowadays nowadays in the world
YouTube I just don't think there's any
point to the point now I don't think I
could do it anyway um because there's
millions of people can't appeal to it
there's two people in this world so you
can go ahead and target our target yeah
I mean you know lots lots of I'm an
acquired taste I'm just alright here's
my advice what's his name again
John John okay John here's my advice to
you get off into this Carl young stuff
I'm starting to get into it myself you
can go on youtubes didn't look at Carl
Jung's red book and then all the other
books that he there's guys talking about
it
and on that young guys talking about it
which I mean I'm quite impressed with it
they're reading this books I wouldn't
mind getting these books myself and
start reading them young gets into
alchemy numerology ghosts
synchronicities he says all of those
actually have to do with your
unconscious and that if you can start
breaking down the barriers of your
unconscious and allow that to flow into
your consciousness you'll start having a
weird synchronicities happened you start
having weird paranormal things happen
you can even kind of look at it in a
Star Wars type aspect a lot of the
things that that you know George Lucas
talked about in those original three
star was actually came from Hume yes he
got that from his professor Joseph
Campbell yeah and Campbell was big into
Jung and Campbell wrote his own books
too so Lucas didn't come up with stuff
these are things that have been people
have been experimenting with sometimes
going back thousands of years going back
to weird types of monks yeah you know
they're you know altered states of
consciousness go off into that menu and
and you'll find you'll find what you
need eventually I'm gonna start going in
that direction I think yeah yeah call um
yeah I want to I want to understand what
it is that he was seeing yeah that must
be a like a kind of an interesting
research yeah evidently Freud Freud knew
the quote that Jung was going this way
and he had a check out yeah but
evidently
Jung kind of manifested some spooky
paranormal phenomenon around uh around a
meeting that he and Freud had I think it
was Freud I had to go back to see what
it was I think he was talking to fraud
Freud didn't believe it and some
paranormal some some PK RSP you know uh
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
happened in the damn same room with
Freud Freud he kind of balked and ran
yeah you didn't want anything to do with
that it was to create creeped him out
he says you watch what happens in
something fail he goes watch it'll
happen again in something else fell you
know and we've had things fall around
Freud was like no do the fact that he
was kind of doing weird stuff with kinda
like altered states of consciousness as
he was falling asleep trying to
interpret dreams and interpret his
visions and he was doing kind of like
what you would call to me based on based
on what these kid with the guys that are
making the videos what they were saying
it sounded like he was trying to kind of
go through some of the stuff that you
people try to do when they're astrally
project yeah or to have an out-of-body
experience you're going through those
Indian chakras which that was kind of
something that happened to me when I had
that out-of-body experience I read about
these chakras and how certain people you
know could induce an out-of-body
experience and I was like well that's
kinda the way it felt when I did it
spontaneously yeah I wasn't envisioning
any kind of shock where is there
anything you know it was just a weird
feeling of vibration starting at your
feet going up through your body to your
head it felt like your head was moving
next thing you know is looking down you
know looking down on the room yeah so
John was messing around with stuff like
that
to kind of like remote viewing and
visions so if you I would read what I
would read what what he said I don't
know exactly because I haven't read the
books yet but just based on the videos
that I've been watched in the past week
or so that sounds a lot like what I
experienced yeah so I think Jim was onto
something at least maybe an aspect of it
yeah it's like I said that might be kind
of an interesting now yeah wrap it whole
to go down sure
yeah and evidently you know Kubrick kind
of thought the same yeah like what I was
watching this video about kind of a
Jungian interpretation of the shining I
was like a lot of it that a lot of it
makes sense I got it I got a say you
know I mean yeah and she's seen it she's
seen it in the house she's seen stuff
like you know remotes fly off and my mom
saw damn [ __ ] being
shelf pulled down and statues of horses
thrown on the kitchen floor you got on
the kitchen floor it's just I mean yeah
it hasn't happened a lot but and I was
gonna say to when I was reading that
story about like him hearing the
knocking I have to get bent out of shape
I am I have heard the doorbell ringing
in the middle of the night there was
nobody there
I didn't hear it but I went out and
checked yeah I heard it I was awake yeah
it wasn't like a thing where it's like I
was sleeping or nothing like because I'd
been awake for awhile because sometimes
I wake up in the night cuz I have to go
the bathroom runner ever and then I come
back to been cooking if I sleep so I was
laying there and I heard the doorbell
and I even thought after it after the
doorbell went off because it was 4:00 in
the morning yeah
4:28 I think it was burning enclosed
community we're in a gated community
yeah and it went off and then like I
heard it and I was like holy [ __ ] and
like I got really scared and I was
laying there I was like okay I know I
heard that but maybe I imagined it but
then about 30 seconds later it did it
again and then I was just kind of like
that's when I woke you up the second
time I didn't wake you up the first time
it rang a second time and then I woke
you up because I thought someone was out
there yeah and nobody was nobody was the
garage door is open - yeah well yeah I
was - because I really wanted that to be
my imagination I keep - Garage Door
unplugged now yeah yeah you can't open
on its own use an electric power yeah
because I know like that I'm afraid of
that my hat well that could have like an
explanation because sometimes you can
get if you have like the clicker thing
because we do have that yet you could
drive around you can drive around and
like open people's garages you know if
your thing is on the same that was
earlier than that garage door opened
yeah that was the middle of night - I
think that was like three or four night
and what was weird is that that kind of
stuff resurfaced when we were right in
the book and and we were talking and
talking about it a lot and I start was
worrying about it at the time yeah and
some of the stuff that these guys are
saying that Zhang Soyoung said kind of
indicate that you if you think about
this stuff too long and have an
emotional reaction towards it or worry
about it too long it manifests and well
do with that Jungian unconscious and yet
and although like I said that that yummy
and unconscious but also Hameroff would
just call that the quantum consciousness
yeah
then it's that it's kind of spread out
throughout the universe too that you can
become aware of anything your soul yeah
you know that's the Christian version of
it your soul and your soul is kind of
has it it's like a super soul it knows
you know it's godlike being it knows
more than you do I just thought it's a
comic book cover yeah your soul is your
soul is a lot older than your than your
material body you know I mean we only
have the memories or this life but your
soul has memories from many lives and
it's kind of like a super-ego yeah and
it's tight and it's woven in with the
fabric of the universe it could be
anywhere to need any time and can direct
travel through time and you know so
that's what you'll get from what I
understand that's what Jung was saying
and he said had different aspects of it
and anima and I can't remember more like
I said I haven't studied young yet yeah
I gotta get off into that but do well
when you were saying about the garage
door though the creepy thing about that
is like yeah that could have been
explained by somebody going by with a
clicker that was on the same frequency
but when we went to check on it the door
from the laundry room into the garage
also opened inward yeah and if he
doesn't open like that that was creepy
because the thing about like you open
that door you have to like put something
there to keep it open because it'll just
close on its own but it very very slowly
opened inward I remember that into the
laundry room yeah and that that made
like the hairs on the back of my neck
stand up because that's not how that
door works yeah that did that did remind
me of blows blows yeah because I'm
looking at it go now is that door doing
that although the remote the remote and
all the statues that was definitely blow
stuff but well yeah there was no way
that could have been anything else
because we were all sitting there like
if there is those funnies that that
happened so fast it didn't scare me it's
a slower [ __ ] that happens that it
didn't scare me I thought it was kind of
neat well it's like for a second like I
was just surprised
you know what I mean cuz I was like oh
well okay and then like first I guess
I'm a tree were like Jenni to meet you
were stunned yeah they were just and
then we all just kind of like looked at
each other like did you just touch
features that Tom dude he had do it
again I said no no no yeah like the
whole atmosphere got like really weird
that I was falling backwards
alright so okay so I'm gonna do some
more movie recommendations and then
after that I have three short fiction
pieces and then we will eventually wrap
them you need hours it's probably gonna
be like five hours I'm saying well like
I said I wanted to get at least one of
everybody's stories in alright and I
wanted to do like make a recommendation
alright so the move your recommendation
of doing now now these are all on to b2b
TV which is free yes there's commercials
but there's not that many you know maybe
one every half an hour something like
that so it's really not that big a deal
so [ __ ] that is on to be right now that
I would recommend if you like see style
horror and you have not seen your next
you need to really see that that is on
to be at the moment there's also one
called triangle which is from 2009
because there's a couple different
movies that are called triangle or the
triangle this is the one from 2009 I
think it's a British movie and it's
basically about these people then
they're like on a ship and then it's
like a shipwreck but then they find like
a cruise ship and get on it and there's
like nobody on there yeah that was a
good movie and then yeah this is like a
mindfuck it's pretty it's like one of
those weird like time distortion this
movie reminded me of death ship if you
guys are old enough to remember death
ship that was yeah I found an old Hulk
derelict floating through the ocean and
they board it it's like a big [ __ ]
yeah a tanker but like a cargo ship
there's something creepy about like
abandoned and it had a bunch of dead
Jews on it from the Damned Holocaust it
was an old nod yes yeah that's right and
it was it was haunted his [ __ ] and that
kind of reminded me of that there might
be on to be to remember incorrectly
yeah maybe that ship was spooky I saw it
scared the [ __ ] out of me
the cargo hold was filled a bunch of
like I said all rotten Jewish dudes
there it's imagine imagine ow sh whit's
but on a ship out in the ocean
yeah and like you just stumbling across
yeah that movie inspired me to do the
show that we did about the [ __ ] weird
like go ships those ships yeah cuz there
there are ships floating out and out in
the ocean right now right now yeah big
ones think about that you bit that have
been derelict family is like drifting
around maybe they do the ones that don't
[ __ ] with my leg I'm gonna [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] with my Halloween fantasies yeah
it's creepier when you think about it
like I know what's your problem you're
your little buddy needs to like help you
out no no the one of the one of the
weird ones is that one of the weird
words I heard about was a big old shift
of us and I think it was some something
from like a Filipino ship or something
and it's been floating out there for
like 25 30 years and it appears every
now and then evidently like every seven
or eight years somebody comes across it
it's just floating around right yeah
Granderson takes place he also it's like
yeah yeah I could just be floating
around for years and years and nobody
comes across it and then I'm still
floating and they say that it's just
like an infested
it's just infested with cannibalistic
rats and [ __ ] roaches and [ __ ] yeah
you would think that they'd all be dead
now that the biomass would have eaten
itself but could just be a legend yeah
rats and stuff cannibalistic rat ship
yeah that the next time I originally get
on it rats start trying to eat you yeah
yeah well it'd be awesome for the rats
they'd be like whoo all right buffet
yeah so triangle 2009 that is on to be
also I think I mentioned this one before
probably at another show like in an
offhand comment it's called the bay
it's a mockumentary and I tend to like
mockumentary is better than like
straight-up found footage this is like a
really really good one it's kind of like
about it um sort of like about a plague
sort of thing that happens like on this
island like over the summer and it's
done really well like it's really really
creepy so check that one on also
there's one on there and I had forgotten
all about this movie but it's from back
in 2003 and it's called dead end there's
a lot of movies called that but like I
said this is from 2003 brain-wise isn't
it it's basically this is this kind of
movie where it takes place on like a
single stretch of road it's like a
family that's going like I don't know
bored they're going but they're doing
like on some road trip or something
their car breaks down or whatever and
then like all this really weird it's
kind of one of those things where it's
like oh we've circled back to where we
were and it's like you know there's one
of them dies and the body disappears and
it's like there's all kind of like weird
like surreal [ __ ] going on but it's like
really really really good it's like I
hadn't seen it for years and years and
then I saw it again on there and I was
like holy crap I forgot like how good
this movie was so yeah that's on there
I've mentioned this one before too this
another mockumentary lake mungo this
needs a [ __ ] blu-ray release and [ __ ]
like that cuz I know this is one is
legit one of the scariest like creepiest
movies I've ever seen it's so [ __ ]
your EP um I think it's 2009 I want to
say somewhere around there he doesn't
release I if it does it's like a really
cheap jak1 okay
like I was watching like some other
channel and they were mad too because
it's like they have it was just like one
of those DVDs that was like under you
know how they used to do this like cheap
DVDs that were just like you know some
production company this was like hey
here's this cheap-ass movie and they'd
sell them for like three dollars it was
one of those but it was like but this
movie is so good it's so good and it's
like if you legit did not know that this
was a mockumentary you would think this
was a real thing that's how good the
acting is everybody is exactly like a
real person it's Australian and it's
basically about you know this girl that
dies and then like they think that her
ghost is haunting it but there's like
all kind of other [ __ ] going on and it's
just really really good like the way
it's just this is very very subtle like
slow burn it's super super creepy it's
really good and I don't know why it
doesn't get more attention but whatever
um another found footage one that's
actually pretty damn good is the put Kip
C tapes which is kind of like a serial
killer found footage kind of angle
there's also one called butterfly kisses
which is kind of a little bit Blair
Witch II it's kind of like the same
thing about somebody like investigating
like a kind of an urban legend type of
thing and then like it's real and [ __ ]
this was actually like much better than
I was expecting so that's a good one as
well there's one called dark circles
which is which I liked because it was
like it was kind of these new parents
and they just had a baby and they and so
they were playing on the whole sleep
deprivation angle so like you didn't
know if like all this creepy [ __ ] they
were saying was just because they
weren't getting any sleep because the
[ __ ] baby kept waking them up or if
there was like really some supernatural
[ __ ] going on so I really liked that a
lot
if you liked because we mentioned the
tenant earlier if you liked the tenant
there's this movie called occupant which
I think came out 2008 or somewhere
around there and it reminded me very
much of that is it's basically like this
guy and he inherits this really like
nice apartment in Manhattan like from
his grandmother like cuz she's like his
he's like her only living relative and
you know and he gets it for like super
cheap rent but he has to squat in it for
a while like there's this like legal
loophole you know for rent control and
stuff so he's like squatting in this
apartment for like a couple weeks but he
can't leave and then like the super of
the building is like really helpful but
also really sketchy and then there's
like all this really weird [ __ ] going on
at the building that they don't really
explain and it's like so you're not
really sure how much of it is real it's
very like surrealistic and I really
really dug it I think a lot of people
didn't like it because they were like
well why did this happen they didn't
explain anything but I liked it better
that way like I liked that just all this
weird [ __ ] happened and they're just
like I don't know it was just weird I
think you know what I mean it's like so
it's really good also on their house
bound which was either Australian or New
Zealand more a horror comedy a bit very
good about a girl that's she's under
house arrest and she can't leave and
then the house is haunted
turn her mom I think another Australian
one the loved ones I got to check that
out about kind of a crazy girl that's
holding a like her prom date hostage or
something like that because she has like
all these weird like romantic notions or
whatever the sacrament which is
it's kind of like a found footage but
it's like the Jonestown Massacre but
it's like a modern retelling of it so
like if you know how the Jonestown
Massacre went you'll know how this movie
goes it doesn't it's not about that like
all the names are different but the
story of it is pretty much the same as
the Jonestown Massacre but that well
speaking of the loved ones yeah remember
that movie called the loved one yeah
that was from the 60s right yeah that's
right that's a really good one to Edgar
winters was a guy's name yeah I know
Jonathan winter Jonathan winters and
then it's about a futuristic funeral
home yeah and yeah that was a [ __ ]
good one man that was a [ __ ] guy that
was one movie cuz like like I'm the
horror Joe he knows everything she
didn't know that I had never heard of
that movie and he had seen it and he's
like you need to see this but you would
love this [ __ ] movie and I could not
believe I could not believe I had not
seen that movie it's amazing yeah it's
amazing movie yeah I can't remember
exactly what year but it's from the 60s
right it's black and white yes black and
white I think that's my movie 63 64 so
it's messed up like for that like it was
kind of like kind of like the the
Kubrick movie about the [ __ ] nuclear
war what was oh yeah okay
doctor I like Doctor Strange it did give
me that kind of vibe but it's the
doctors love of funeral homes yeah it
was like that yeah it was like really
ask people that [ __ ] run this damn
funerals it was almost like a proto Tim
Burton move exactly
I bet Tim Burton Magatha in the movie
got this [ __ ] he's cute [ __ ] sixties
goth chicks that are morticians that are
it's really good I got a grab sex with
the [ __ ] guy who runs it who's like a
pseudo preacher and it's almost kind of
like a sex cult in a weird way and guys
trying to date one of them is it was a
[ __ ] bad-ass yeah I really like fire
a [ __ ] a little kid who's like a
rocket scientist and they're the the the
the eventual plan is to send all these
dead people off into space and put them
into orbit yeah [ __ ] and then they
were gonna sell this as some kind of a
spiritual experience
it's almost like an Edward movie but
good good kind of like a lot of social
commentary yeah on people's [ __ ]
beliefs about the afterlife and religion
yeah that you can sell them anything if
you worded it it was super weird maybe
for back then but I dug it called my
loved one it seems like it's kind of
hard to get hold of that is an expensive
blu-ray it is it's a rare move and I
hardly ever hear anybody talking about
it which is probably why I'd never seen
it because when I said when you
recommended it cuz you happen to have
seen it somehow I saw when I was a
little kid and that was like the
beginning of my goth girl fit
fascination oh man that's like right up
my alley yeah and all the girls I've
ever saw all the girls that worked at
the cemetery had like these short mini
dresses on all in black with black veils
yeah remember that [ __ ] yeah it was bad
and he had to be a hot girl to work at
this Dam the guy who ran it was like a
fake preacher yeah yeah yeah it's a
funny movie it's red yeah if you you
should look it up it's not I don't think
it's on like any streaming services I
don't think it's creepy and funny at the
same time yeah yeah like it was way
ahead of its time yeah yeah way if it's
time cool the last one yeah the loved
one yeah the loved ones is it different
that's like the Australian movie that I
was but a loved one is what what that
company who owned the cemetery what was
the code whispering Nona eats the
cemetery had a bunch of damn Center of
different different areas of it's like a
theme park yeah sorta one of it was
called whispering glades yeah that's
right yeah that's Falls of Xanadu yeah
it was it was like it was like a dark
comedy yeah yeah but it was like yeah
yeah like I said really ahead of its
time
yeah you can find that somewhere I don't
know if it's on maybe it's on Amazon per
minute you know all these [ __ ] cute
Lily monsters looking at Lily much more
like Morticia Addams Lisha Adams looking
sixties girls [ __ ] running this damn
cemetery with this kind of pervy Oh like
him and Jonathan winters played like six
roles in it didn't that's right yeah he
was
the priest here it wasn't really a
priest he was just a cemetery owner yeah
yeah and then they played four or five
different guys in there yeah I really
great it's a great movie it really is um
okay so let me see where was I okay so
to be recommendations oh they just put
this one up the other day and I don't
want to see this one for a while this is
called Banshee chapter now this one is
kind of like if you're into like MKULTRA
like conspiracy theory type stuff or
there's a got like Ted Levine
who you know it puts the lotion on its
skin or else it gets those again you
know from Silence of the Lambs he is in
this playing like a Hunter s Thompson
character yeah he's essentially a hunter
as Thompson except to use named
something else so it's basically about
this drug it's kind of like a DMT
variant and when you take it I guess
there's lit there's like a thing where
MKULTRA was experimenting with this
particular kind of drug DMT nineteen I
think it's called in the movie and when
you drink it it not only causes you like
to loosen eight and freak out and [ __ ]
like that but also it seems to like make
something come and get you okay so it's
almost kind of like MKULTRA crossed with
HP Lovecraft's from beyond that's cool
it's very good I'm moving in a banshee
chapter okay it's I really liked it a
lot it's it's weird because it's almost
like he couldn't decide whether he
wanted to make a regular movie or like
found-footage because some of it is like
footage because it's this woman that's
she's um investigating the disappearance
of her best friend who was experimenting
with this drug like to see what it would
because he was writing a research paper
on it and then he disappears and there's
like a weird video of him taking the
drug and then like it freaks out and
there's like all kind of weird [ __ ]
happening so she hooks up with this
Hunter s Thompson character you know to
chart because he was the one that sent
him the drug and they're trying to like
figure out what's going on so yeah so
there's a very from beyond type of vibe
to it in a very like MKULTRA like
government experiment conspiracy theory
in the desert type of [ __ ] so if you're
into that kind of thing I really liked
it a lot and I just watch that one the
other day
another really good one that's on there
and this was on Netflix for a while but
I don't think it's on there anymore but
um it's now on to be for free
and I also recommend this one to
everyone they look like people this is
not a straight-up horror movie it's more
like a psychological I guess it's like a
psychological thriller does have horror
elements like it has like super creepy
like imagery and stuff but it's
basically about a guy who has
schizophrenia and he thinks that people
are demons and that he has to kill them
like you that certain people are demons
so it's kind of like the story of like
him and his best friend and how how he's
trying to like navigate this like mental
illness that he has and it's like this
is one one it's not only one of the
creepiest movies I've ever seen
- it's probably one of the best
depictions of mental illness I've ever
seen it's good because the guy is like
really sympathetic he knows that he has
schizophrenia but he can't discern like
reality from fantasy but he knows that
he can't and it's very disturbing to him
so he's very sympathetic and the ending
of it like the friendship between the
two guys like they established it so
well like the ending of it is super
super it was like touching you know what
I mean and yeah it's weird to say about
like a horror movie but the end of that
I was just like legit I was like oh my
god that wasn't beautiful it was a
beautiful beautiful ending you know what
I mean it's like I'm not gonna spoil it
but it's like I really really liked the
ending of it it was just like perfect so
that's a really good one they look like
people now this is one that that had
been recommended to me a bunch of times
this is kind of like a horror movie it's
more like a dark comedy but it has like
a lot of gore it's called excision and
it's about this girl who has some
serious psychological problems so it's
kind of like going into her kind of
daily life but it's also into her
fantasy life she kind of has like a
weird like necrophilia fetish she has
like all this weird so there's all this
like really beautiful but grotesque like
imagery of like all of her inner
thoughts which are super [ __ ] up and
then like her real life as well and this
movie is from a spot the Cameo
kind of standpoint fantast there's all
kind of like great cameos in this I
don't want to spoil all of them I will
say one John Waters hmm now Traci Lords
has a major part in this Traci Lords
plays the girl's mom damn she's a hottie
yeah so um so there's and there's a
bunch of other ones too in this but it's
it this is really good like I said not
exactly a horror movie it's more like a
black comedy but it's really really gory
the same director his second movie was
called suburban gothic which is on to be
it's also on shudder so if you don't
have shudder you can watch it for free
on to be that was more a straight comedy
but it had paranormal elements to it
like it was a guy that could see dead
people and like you know he was trying
to like figure out what was that that
also had ray wise in it who was in Twin
Peaks in case most people didn't know
but yeah so that was more comedy so it
wasn't I didn't like it quite as much as
exigent but it was still like hilarious
um another one I recommend is absentia
which I think was Mike Flanagan's might
have been his first movie just kind of
like a creepy surreal type of thing
again if you like art flicks remember I
mentioned eyes and my mother before if
you liked that one and if you like the
lighthouse
then you should watch a field in England
this is a weird [ __ ] movie this is
also black and white and it's basically
like for guys who are like deserting
from a battle and one of them is like an
alchemist and then like this other guy
comes and he's like looking for him is
what you're we talking about yeah it's
like 16th century or 17th century
something like that yeah it's like said
a long time ago and um and I think and
and there's some debate over whether all
this [ __ ] that happened in the movie
actually happened or if it was like some
kind of weird like alchemical like a
magical ritual type of thing like I mean
like it could have been interpreted that
way too like a lot if you know a lot
about alka man [ __ ] then you will just
you will be orgasmic at this movie
because it's just like it just like goes
along that whole kind of thing like this
whole journey that this dude is on it's
like super trippy not a lot of people
will be able to put up with it because
it's very very arty-farty
but it's funny to like - it reminded me
of the lighthouse and
a similar kind of vibe when I already
farty [ __ ] goes down she starts getting
uncomfortable around me because she
thinks I'm not gonna like it
well yeah well I have my say I it's
always kind of like stressful for me
like not not so much like at home like
because I can just like watch it in my
office by myself but if but if we're in
a movie theater yeah like I can't tell
like if you like [ __ ] or not because
he's always well because whether he
likes a movie or not I can't ever tell
ya because his tastes are very weird and
like idiosyncratic but it's like
whatever movie it is I see him sitting
over there and whatever movie it is it
doesn't matter if he likes it or not he
always does stuff like he's always doing
that kind of stuff and I can always see
that at the core my I'm like is he just
doing that cuz he's breathing or is he
doing that because he's mad so I'm
always like so it kind of takes me out
of the movie a little bit cuz I'm like
worrying about like like what is his
problem over there it's like he might
just be doing that just for no reason
why not just reacting to it cuz
sometimes he's done that and I thought
oh my god he's hating this [ __ ] and then
I get stressed out but then later he's
like oh man that was awesome you know
what I mean so yeah well what was what
was that all about
yeah because sometimes you're like oh
man like you're into the movies
sometimes I can't tell that from like oh
[ __ ] this movie I can't tell so it could
be either depends that's what I mean I
can't tell the difference between those
two reactions so a lot of times if we
see something especially if it's
something that I really wanted to see
like I was very nervous about going to
see the lighthouse because I knew I was
probably gonna dig it because I had seen
the witch and I was really into it how
did you do on that one you didn't see
the witch and I figured because I knew
it was gonna be arty-farty
yeah because that's just what that guy
does and so I was like well I was like
man I really want to see this and I hope
he doesn't like complain about it the
whole time or like inflater out of the
car the whole time but it's like but
then like when I was watching the movie
I got so into it I didn't give a [ __ ]
anymore because I was just like cuz I
got like so sucked into the movie so I
wasn't really worried about what you
were I appreciate ya and then why are
you laughing at it a couple times so I
was like well that's good cuz he laughed
at like funny parts
ya know I like the movie I didn't say I
like I like the movie but I was like I
liked it more the more I think about it
actually the movie was supposed to [ __ ]
you over mmm
alright I was trying to see in which
which I know that the movies trying to
do that so I'm kind of in a personal
struggle with them you're not really
involved in that [ __ ] I'm kind of like
mentally spiritually Carol like
struggling with it I want to talk about
it until it's [ __ ] totally digested
it yeah that's definitely one that needs
to be I'm trying to side against it and
I'm trying to psychoanalyze the dudes
that made it yeah and why they were
trying to [ __ ] me over like that and
then I start critiquing well how good
was that [ __ ] over and did I [ __ ]
actually counter [ __ ] over that movie
like to go through the [ __ ] isn't this a
great deal of that I'm talking about
yeah I was not happy with that straight
back they said they achieve what they
tried to do yeah someone give him props
for it okay well that's good I was
actually I saw like a snippet of an
interview today with with Robert Eggers
and he said the best [ __ ] thing about
this movie he said and I'm paraphrasing
but this is pretty much what he said he
said we're talking about the Whitehead
yep he said nothing good ever comes from
two men being trapped in a giant phallic
symbol I can relate to it personally
being on a desert island during mission
on op3 11 also known as the rock yeah
look it up MFO mission the Egypt look it
up on YouTube but we was like six to
eight of us depend on up there so I know
what I understand that situation yeah
and like I said and I've seen a couple
our situation was not that die well that
was in a very extreme way how people
would go not extreme situation so I
could I could so I could put myself in
those shoes yeah one on the rock we
actually [ __ ] partied yeah we loved
it yeah
well they did to just see this you know
horrible horrible accident to the cure
do our jobs and enforcing the embargo
against [ __ ] Iran Saddam was still
alive at that time so we were having fun
up there
yeah doing helicopter missions and [ __ ]
no we're not having fun not running
generators and burnin [ __ ] because we
didn't have a sewage system we just had
that damn outhouse so we'd have to pour
diesel fuel in the [ __ ] just like in the
garden yeah this [ __ ] the young guys
like to do yeah
burning [ __ ] okay I'm burnish it hold on
but yeah another I was reading another
review of the lighthouse and somebody
like kind of pegged it they said you
know that and they gave like the maybe a
very glowing review but they're like
this is like what would is like the
worst like roommate situation ever like
it's a horror movie about like having
the worst roommate ever say you know
this you know those Egyptian misses yeah
I saved like five of them did you yeah
because around op3 11 is a bunch of
concertina wire it's wrapped up [ __ ]
like barbed wire and you'd have to walk
that [ __ ] wire once a day and you'd
find [ __ ] birds as hisses yeah
[ __ ] trees knocking there sir yeah
because the the wind velocity was high
as it would go up the mountain and they
were just trying to soar up through this
thermals go through the wind currents
and [ __ ] and they'd run into that
concertina I must have pulled four or
five of them things out of oil genet oh
nice yeah you pulled him out of there
you know not take him down into the main
bunker into the machine gun bunker that
we had let him recover and feed them and
everything and they were like thankful
well yeah they're not dumb but they're
smart yeah you go up there you get them
out of there
their [ __ ] wings and be all cut up
from being caught in the [ __ ] I mean
they understand like people trying to
help them yeah I [ __ ] would get them
other guys would do it too I guess we
got about five of them I guys got too
personally yeah
pulled mile of wire and you'd like curl
them up like a chicken until I'd fold
them up their wings you know I'm [ __ ]
pet him take him out let him recover
just put them on the ground it'd be
about four hours before they recover and
then they walk outside the bunker spread
their wings
the air went and let the wind to carry
them away you know yeah and you can sell
they were [ __ ] looking down at the
camp like thanks man thanks man you know
and they take off yeah give us some
sardines oh I bet they really that's
probably their favorite things yeah nice
and stinky give us some stink yes all
right so the last movie that I'm gonna
recommend on TV and like I said there's
a [ __ ] they have a Hugh mongus horror
selection I didn't even looked at like
some of their other topics cuz they have
like the [ __ ] documentaries they have
everything but um you know a lot of them
I had to kind of wade through there's a
lot of good old ones on there like I
said to you but I'm not gonna like
recommend those because you know you
guys know but I'm just trying to do ones
that aren't that old now the last one
I'm gonna recommend is called the
children and it's from 2009 this is also
a British movie I actually heard about
this one from top 5 scary videos that
guy he's a British guy Jack Finch and he
he does like a series where it's like
you know top five like you know
underrated horror movies or horror
movies you haven't seen or something
like that and he's done like eight or
nine of those so I write down like if
some of them I've seen but like some of
my work done and this was one of the
ones that he recommended and I found it
on to be and it's really really good
it's just kind of like it reminded me
slightly I'd I want to say the brood but
not quite it's kind of like a thing
where like all the kids turn evil for
whatever reason I'm gonna start killing
the adults and stuff you know it's kind
of set at Christmas time and stuff like
that but I really really liked it so go
check that one out as well as from 2009
alright so before we wrap up this very
long show holy crap I'm so glad that we
decided to be some marathons record this
over two nights because it's like it's
gonna put this on and I have a whole
Halloween festival that's what I mean
it's like holy [ __ ] this is gonna be
seriously when I edit this together it's
gonna be almost six hours long
ridiculous this is a I didn't mean to be
in the fog I just met pretty maybe three
hours but you know how we go it's like
just kind of like we start drinking he
starts talking we just kind of flicked
you gonna blame it on me
why is that well no I'm just I'm not
blaming it on you I'm just saying like
[ __ ] happening oh you you guys hang
actually the great Mozingo yeah bravest
[ __ ] no it's not like the mediocre yeah
you got im so we got like really into
that you were really into that for a
while and we were like watching the
cartoon and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
superheroes you grew up watching this
yeah grew up watching but it's like
there's a like there's a little person
in there right it's kind of it's like og
Kabuto and I forgot the other guy's name
it's a long story
they were in a damn UFOs in a secret
Institute making [ __ ] secret
technology and then grendizer came down
and that was kind of like the Japanese
Superman
yeah and forgot what his name was and
I'm putting a drop right now but yeah he
had an alien super robot called Grand
Iser yeah yeah and they were saving a
planet like he did yeah everything
everything that was superhero in Japan
you had the hero and he had a giant
robot well yeah okay because that's
clearly the way yeah boy Spiderman and
gave him a spider just giant robot
because everybody has a giant robots
right they even had BOTS just how it
works they bought the license for
Superman and so he wouldn't wait what
did Superman's giant robot look like did
it look like Superman or didn't know I
[ __ ] it come be called bull mark made
the damn diecast figure I bought it when
I was a kid I forgot what it was called
[ __ ] it was silver with red I mean it
was just look like a damn robot I could
probably do the little yeah Superman's
wrote Superman's mecha
it said now I'm kind of like here here
like I feel like it looks pissed off it
looked like it it looked kind of like
Pharaoh okay
I feel like Superman wouldn't need a
mecha but if you have the opportunity to
be given one you'd be like why not yeah
why not wear a robot giant robot look
like Pharaoh in a way
okay but the lines but actually no you
know what you know what Superman's giant
robot look like what they look more like
[ __ ] it looked like more like [ __ ]
damn it look it look basically kind of
Greek okay okay it had a face and it had
it have four little [ __ ] things that
went back and it had big arms that kind
of bowled out three spikes on the back
of the arms and big fists and this is
dumb it looked it looked it looked kind
of like something from ancient Persia
okay what I don't know that sounds
pretty bad as I think so I'm really
trying we're really trying not to go off
any tangents but yeah you know how that
works
yeah so before we end this like [ __ ]
marathon of a show I wanted to read
three fiction pieces that were submitted
and like I said some of you guys like
sent me too but like I said I picked the
shorter one because you know like I said
this show is like I did not expect the
show to go on this long so I was gonna
my demands Mecca was called Leopold and
Leopold II Leopold Dion Leopold II on
was its name Leopold II on there now it
looks stupid it looks stupid yeah
there's a bunch of squares and a [ __ ]
weird-looking beak and a [ __ ] head
spider [ __ ] the spiderweb looking
pattern on it Leopold II on okay some
people loved it they made it be for my
man a bit like this of Leopold yeah they
made him different sizes Leopold young
spider-man's mecha yeah yeah that's the
direction that I didn't think yeah yeah
interesting but I forgot Superman's one
so like every American superhero had
their own giant robot know from what I
remember the good from when I remember
back in the 70s did Wonder Woman have on
know they only bar some Isis to
spider-man and Superman how would I
remember they may have bought like some
of the other ones but I don't remember
it I don't think they had mech isn't
[ __ ] but the thing is a Japanese kid to
be like what is a dude in a leotard some
kind of stupid [ __ ] is that where's this
robot
just a guy was this my unit
yeah they understood they understood
that yes works is giant robot so they
it's a legitimate one there's a lot of
the same but really when it came to
[ __ ] writing the best one was [ __ ]
UFO grand Iser yeah yeah UFO grad dizer
that was that was that what someone see
I like get a robo because get hurt the
getter robo was good because the theme
song is yes and I know things gonna get
a robo G yeah right yeah but I would
still probably put UFO grand Iser above
all that and that was like that was kind
of like the Japanese version of Superman
okay and the writer was really good he
wrote the same writer wrote get a robo
Jeep yeah yeah got his name I like that
one just because like a like I like the
same time yeah they're all kind of
similar but I and it was the same the
same guy like sang a lot of them too
yeah yeah yeah the theme songs were
[ __ ] epic [ __ ] epic well it was
like an orion type guy were you gonna
come out like in a cape and see exactly
saying all that i can't remember his
name was now but I used to have like a
mixed murmur you still listed that mix
in the car so yeah like it's kind of
like halfway Newton but it was awesome
it's awesome yeah and he was singing
about songs of heroism and [ __ ] about
giant robot about giant robots and
aliens who had giant robots that's what
UFO grad guys it was about yeah yeah
yeah
he had Duke fleed was his name that's
right Dib fleed was kind of like the
Japanese Superman he came from another
planet yeah and he arrived here to
protect your pan he has evil white
people they just protect in Japan
against the vegans
the vegan empires your aliens they were
aliens they're from another planet were
they only ate plants yeah
let's call vegan but it was before the
word vegan was so it was it yeah the
vegans of the pagans it was just a word
aliens
yeah yeah he's protecting the earth from
these [ __ ] aliens that's hilarious I
destroyed his home planet okay okay
destroyed his home planet he ran to
earth because they like Superman like
Superman he ran to earth because he can
look like a human and he helped a
[ __ ] he helped Koji Kabuto and some
other guys in a big scientific Institute
to [ __ ] increase their technology to
fight the vegans and he came with Grant
Iser who was this [ __ ] I'll show you
Grand Iser I got Grand you scared okay
here is he's getting them that's the UFO
grand Iser yeah there you go okay and
it's a robot inside of a UFO that flies
yeah and grand Iser please and like it's
a transformer right like yeah he comes
out of there and he will come out of
there just I don't want to do that right
now and great he would pilot that thing
and grand Iser was [ __ ] defending the
earth against the vegans now here's the
thing defending the earth is the Vegas
that's just like that's great here's the
thing though Duke fleed didn't build
this he stole it from the vegans this so
this was a vegan secret weapon it was
their best robot Sophie are you out
there Sophie there yeah he stole it from
the vegans and then ran to Earth with it
it was their secret weapon and used it
against the vegans the defender so it
wasn't his [ __ ] dupe flees [ __ ]
race they were peaceful they didn't
build this kind of [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
yeah they just had to steal the evils
they had to steal it yeah evil people
from you of people yeah and use it
against right but it was the same basic
but he was also a badass he could
[ __ ] flip and kick your ass and she
he was kind of like Superman yeah we
didn't have superpowers he was just
badass martial artists okay well yeah
they all were yes
like I said having a giant robot helps
to yeah just like when you needed a
giant robot because the aliens would
attack and attack you in these giant
robots yeah yeah which I got so it's
like a giant robot arms raised
yeah a person gets a giant robot
everybody needs and I got some of the
bad guys up there of the [ __ ] alien
giant robots the gentian and guys can't
see it a huge huge bunch of robots so
huge
my friend is Japan over company that
makes that yeah yeah yeah he's bridge
guy right but he's a French cavity he
got a Japanese wife yeah and he he makes
all those in sales and he's the same age
as me and he grew up with it he owns a
company makes all [ __ ] toys for it
but they make it for old guys they're
all made of metal that's all metal
they're very nice yeah yeah they're
expensive but they're very expensive and
they're all made out of metal and they
all [ __ ] articulated [ __ ] well I got
up there got Jinjin and I got gear of
gear oh he's cutting is another one he's
gonna call [ __ ] King Gauri's coming
which is like the Japanese Godzilla yeah
baby but he was a cybernetic God it's
Japanese so he now Godzilla I meant King
Kong
yeah okay he's a cybernetic King Kong
King gory can't gorilla what they were
talking to my gotcha and he was a giant
gorilla because that guy gorilla yeah he
was cybernetic nice he was part robot
and part King Kong I like it kids
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] man
they knew exactly what they were doing
they sold so much [ __ ] toys that's
where all these shogun warriors came
from it came from that era well you grew
up in California and they have like some
Japanese TV stations that they shared
like all those cars yeah yeah call I had
I hadn't heard of them until I you ain't
you have channel 22 there was a Japanese
channel and I grew up watching it yeah
but I couldn't understand it I just yeah
they weren't dubbed or no no but I
didn't didn't have to be dubbed that
[ __ ] man those [ __ ] cartoons were
kicking my ass
[Laughter]
care what they're saying the only thing
that got me off that kind of a Star Wars
Star Wars came out
yeah Star Wars could compete with that
yeah but up until Star Wars nothing
could compete with what the Japanese
were doing in anime they were very
attentive there yeah
at a time here's the thing I didn't know
at the time we're going on a sidetrack
but we're going that's ok whatever your
parents hated that [ __ ] well I didn't
want their kids watching that I feel
like parents in general hate everything
their kids had demons involved in it
that's right the girls all had damn
nipples on their uniforms yep
they [ __ ] were there was too much
[ __ ] sex involved in it and the
cartoons are even worse yeah now the
cartoons the the comic books the comic
books are even more racing they're most
like hand tied and certainly yes
he's like perverted [ __ ] tentacle porn -
yeah we're not really you know do weird
[ __ ] with drugs and doing weird [ __ ]
with demon spirits and stuff so I can
remember my mom said this thing's look
demonic she's pining for me anyway
anyway but they did they look like back
in the cities are like demons demon it
does kind of hello he was actually built
after like a European night but you know
that's been yeah it never gave me a
demonic thing I always thought of like
yeah like a Middle Ages yeah thing
that's what I always kind of like that
out of it alright so like I said she was
gonna be like six hours long like a
million hours long a million hours long
that's how long it's gonna be this you
know how long it's gonna take me to
upload to YouTube
very long - yeah but what uh okay I was
sorry baby cookies like over there like
climbing up on the window real quick
okay because we were talking about here
we go but you got to put the camera back
where it was camera that didn't move
okay I thought you were gonna like move
the camera this is gay that's get a robe
oh yeah now you can see what I'm talking
about how demonic that was yeah that was
yeah all right now as he's put in front
of my client bugger book back there yes
all right all right well I hope this
kind of keep kava okay so like I said
before we end this endless endless show
yeah I have three fiction pieces I want
to read all right yeah do you think you
can settle down long enough for me to do
that yeah okay
I hope you guys love us because you're
getting a lot of us this although more
of us than anyone should ever have to
endure I'm already sick of us and I'm
and I'm me you know what I mean I'm
already sick of me all right so this
first story like I said okay you get in
your little okay he's gonna listen okay
so this is a story that was sent to me
by zachary lee antal who i talked to
quite a bit he sent me two stories this
was like the shorter one so this is what
I'm going to read this one is called the
blessed few all right are we ready yeah
everyone okay Pennsylvania was a
contradiction Philly being the home of
the American ideal while coal country as
it was known to the locals could easily
pass for the kind of backwater one finds
in parts of Siberia Wales or the African
Gold Coast I should know because I've
lived in coal country and Wales for a
little while the clattering elevator
arrived at the natural entrance to the
mine the men inside letting out a
collective sigh most pulled off their
hats and gloves to wipe their brows the
sweat mixing with the coal dust to make
a fine powder use across the skin
Terence stretching and pulling on every
tendon until there was just the right
amount of pop to satisfy didn't follow
the others nah he went his own way
molten that of his coveralls and
flinging him into the bed of his
mud-caked f series lamenting the fact
that he'd had to clean both of them
eventually the smokestacks made him sit
up and take notice on the road home
their smoke looking more like the ink
from an octopus thick enough to block
out the Sun Terence imagined the area
frozen wasteland a volcanic winter of
man's own making he adored winter and
found the thought soothing as the
cicadas sung their song from the trees
come to think of it he'd never seen one
of them before all he'd ever known of
him were when grandpa told him the
singin was the sound they made during
fornication which it is we have those
around here
Terence smiled at it always having
preferred vocal women as his partners at
night women like Gail or as her Papa
called her once upon a time Gil as it
was impossible to get her out of the
local pond as a girl
nor made any kind of sound while on her
back in the dark with the curtains
closed
Fatima couldn't have been more different
of a story she said she'd come from
Guadalajara or some such place at the
end of the war to find work what little
he remembered of her talk ran something
to the tune of maid de Londres -
waitress - flamenco club dancer - hooker
no streetwalker she swore a high-class
lady of the night
Terrance had no way of proving it even
if he had cared - finding her the first
time in response to an ad for a nanny
Gale had to get a filly to care for aunt
Margo her dementia praecox getting more
and more out of hand
the pay was $5 an hour many responders
Terence could see himself leaving with
the kids and not coming home to find
them in the rest of the house missin
then in watts Fatima where in a
converted men's suit from the war years
her waterfall of black hair covered by a
scarf ever so perfectly bowed under her
chin it was this hair in fact along with
her almond eyes high cheeks and dark
complexion that stuck out to him she
reminded him of his first time at 16
with a very beautiful little Juan Indian
girl in a wheat field heard the daughter
of a local moonshiner who daddy had
gotten friendly with in prohibition the
children were unusually taken with her
including the mute Samuel responding
well to the faces she'd made to get him
laughing Gale returned home after a week
Margo had taken a toll she being a
couple pounds lighter than before with
circles under her eyes which also seemed
puffy from crying
Terence wanted to ask why stopping
himself when he realized how little
energy he had to keep up with her tails
Fatima was dismissed you could still
smell the honey scent of her perfume in
the couch fabric for days afterward this
made him begin looking at Gale a time
she was like an intruder she was a
different lady after the miscarriage all
her wit ambition and charm left with max
she hadn't touched Terence or herself in
over three years the next time he saw
Fatima was it at the theater and Lee
Hite Lehighton I guess that is he and
Gail were leaving a screen in the Guys
and Dolls across the street Fatima was
wrapped around the arm of another
Mexican and greaser garb Terence thought
she saw him her waving at him such as in
such a way it made one of her breasts
nearly fell out of the loose peasant top
she wore over the following weeks the
ability not to see her around town was
impossible to keep going
Tarrance even had to stop himself from
misidentifying locals as her in public
he even called her one night hanging up
to second the receiver was lifted on her
end he made up his mind while pic axing
at a vein of coal under the hills sparks
flew out at him one burned him on the
cheek narrowly missing his eye and omen
maybe Daddy latched him with his belt
and he had said such things out loud
Fatima woke at midnight that night a
nightmare
her mother waving goodbye to her as the
train pulled away her father placed a
hand on her shoulder leaning over her he
whispered that she hated her
Fatima got up and brushed her teeth
dispose of the scraps of fabric that was
once a wrap dress and cleaned up the
broken glass under the living-room
window she got back in bed next to
Terence time was to become a nonentity
to the pair's the affair progressed the
talking darker the compliments more
backhanded the lovemaking meaner
eventually Fatima even stopped cleaning
up the black soot of his shoe prints on
the living room carpet playing a game of
hopscotch with them imagining herself
with Terence there was then the issue of
Gayle and her lovely but prying eyes one
wonders what goes in any person's head
the amount of energy it takes to be that
paranoid to make sure all parts of your
life were made in check Terence never
questioned none of it finding they who
seek answers to all things to be exum at
best and a distracting stain on his
reality at worst especially when it
comes to his reality his brain turned to
tars he thought these things over
watching Gayle sleep for a moment
imagining her peaceful expression was
because her body was on the slab then
the sound started up again the awful
sounds like water boiling and being
gargled mixed with the sounds of messy
wet kissing they came from the corner
this time the black tentacles slithering
and banging against each other from the
ceiling like a blind man in a dark room
but all stopped when he looked they
looked back all going rigid and pointing
at him
Terence nodded the next morning was one
of energy for Terence his complete lack
of sleep notwithstanding he fetched
Fatima from the apartment telling her
the tickets to Miami were in order and
then from there on to Havana he had to
make a stop at the mine on the way
though there were tools he'd left he had
to get mentally sighing when she caught
the hook his prayers were all keeping
the elevator from disintegrating out
from under
it claimed reaching the bottom landing
the air was strangled in fumes and
natural gases mud and dust thick enough
through the lighting in a welding tool
may as well send the state into orbit
he'd gone down tunnels upon tunnels upon
tunnels for the umpteenth time had he
not known better he'd have thought he'd
eventually opened a manhole in the
middle of Peking it was only then that
he made it to the pit he placed the
lantern on the old workman's table and
producing a cloth from his pocket
wrapped like a baby would be unfurling
it he turned his hand over Gail's heart
fell into the advanced darkness at the
mouth 10 Mississippi's later he heard
not a peep not a sound of satisfaction
nor displeasure he got down on his knees
praying to the Almighty below him he
wanted needed good fortune in this
endeavor he and she need not be found
nor the children the sisters at care for
him
a single oily tentacle inched up out of
the dark pointing at him it grabbed his
hand the pain beyond ones wildest
nightmares the tentacle then slid out of
his Terrence looking at his palm a brand
running across it as if cattle prodded
he smiled his Lords blessing hmm I like
that sorry very Lovecraftian yeah and
I've seen a lot of people like compare
it to that too it's very big on esque
yeah you know what I mean but this gave
me a very like Lovecraftian vibe also
it's a good job there that's like and
and the whole mind thing when I lived in
Wales for a little while I actually went
down an actual coal mine which you could
go go down it was like a tourist thing
now and I'm super into that like I like
old coal mines and caves and [ __ ] like
that so I was like yeah man I want to go
like way down and so I put on the helmet
and that like went that way down the
[ __ ] elevator and [ __ ] and went down
in the mine and it was all like closed
it was cool man I liked it
I can't learn where it was though what
the [ __ ] was the name of that town well
I was just like an old collie that you
know they didn't um I wasn't open
anymore but they was just like open as a
tourist thing like for people that
wanted to get out and like check out
what it was like to work down in the
mines when everyone goes when everybody
had to work down the mines and Wales
[ __ ] might have been in mirth or TED
Bowl I think because it was that was
like a big coal producing area Wales so
the next story that I have to read was
submitted by someone whose pen name is
Harry Novak this story is called a
murder of souls a cloud choked sky
brooded over Pontefract Park that green
expanse of grass and bush
planted in the ancient market town The
Hulk of the racecourse Building brooded
in the perishing light of dusk its doors
long since locked in the exact center of
the park a man stood hands and pockets
then jacket twitching slightly in the
breeze the fading light showed a
strained and exhausted face crumpled by
what could only be recognized as fear
the man slumped to the ground
expensively tailored trousers rubbing on
damp grass it's not fair he raged this
shouldn't be happening not to someone
like me me his long well manicured
fingers raked at the grass and a futile
gesture of self-pity fear and
narcissistic rage this man David askwith
to the world Davey to his cronies knew
he was trapped a cool breath caressed
his sweaty brow providing no comfort he
stared towards the stand of trees that
formed a near perfect square around an
ancient wrought iron fence no other
human life walked the park which at
which Asquith knew was bizarre in itself
he had lived in this town all his life
knew it's rhythms its quirks and hidden
depths the fact that no runner dog
walker or squawking group of cider
toting teenagers graced the surface of
the park was wrong no they would not be
allowed here they wouldn't allow it
Davy askwith was only just beginning to
suspect who they were the knowledge
clawing in his mind like a jagged dirty
fingernail for he was a big man was he
not a player sharp and tooled up for any
of the jobs he'd had to do who else
could have stomped out the Leeds firms
like him bloodied the chapel town gangs
into a state of whimpering surrender the
small mining town boy raised in a tiny
flat in the Horse Fair oh and the lasses
they'd thrown themselves at him his
parties became the stuff of underworld
legend where women would fulfill every
depraved whim he had had women on tap
inexhaustible supply won over by dirty
cash and promises of a sparkling life a
sound barely perceptible yanked him out
of his semi trance so it had started as
he had known it would why he even
thought to run to the park was it
perhaps his memories of a place where
he'd felt safe as a child an oasis in
the town far removed from the alcoholic
violence in the box that pass for his
home
a solitary car flicked up the a 639 its
lights penetrating the lengthening to
shadows darkness fell upon him like an
old and damp coat the outside lights of
the Sports Center seeming like the LEDs
of some offshore oil rig he began to
move automaton like towards the stand of
trees around a hundred yards away from
him the breeze gathered strength urging
him on like a gentle yet firm hand yes
it had started had he really thought he
could do as he pleased forever the
arrogance of his condition had painfully
crashed upon him dragging him toward his
fate what did the family of the woman
said in their note to him you will see
just three words signed with names he
had previously thought of no consequence
more sounds intruded upon the night air
the night by now fully dead slipping
into its temporary grave beyond the
horizon a whispering crescendo swirled
around him like a swarm of wasps
snatches of conversations long-forgotten
deadly orders given and executed he had
truly thought he could not be crossed
not even by those bastards in London
with her guns and flashy suits the
whispering intents now seemed to assail
him from all sides twisting icy terror
began to gnaw his guts sweat sprang from
every pore reaching the fence the
railings looking like an iron giant's
rusted teeth he slumped forward all
strength seeping from his formerly
powerful body the shadows around him
began to merge in coalesce taking on
barely distinguishable forms fear
reached a gnarled hand into his heart
twisting and yanking he saw the forms
now for what they were a massive
torturous ray flake energy created by
the evil of his actions bleeding into
the cracks in the world waiting for the
right key to return them a key had been
provided one casual act of Cruelty
providing the impetus Christ I didn't
mean to I just couldn't stop I made it
quick he howled futile and desperate
knowing it made no difference inky
blackness swirled around him a
kaleidoscope of shadow shapes forming
and collapsing just as quickly his
terrified mind began to make some sort
of cold sense of his surroundings
the realization of what these figures
represented thudding into his mind like
a meteor crashing to earth one central
figure swirled into place its face
unclear yet askwith knew it didn't need
to be didn't need to be to make itself
known he knew what it had been as surely
as he knew himself the whispering
petered out melting away into the cool
air the figure raised a blurry hand
pointing directly at his weeping eyes
every choice every act of evil and
venality hardened into a diamond point
in his mind
threatening to burst its way out of his
skull one word spoken as one by the
gathered race whispered its way across
the darkness see so David Esquith saw
everything that had been intended for
him to see it was this seeing that
halted his life reducing his brain to a
tepid soup by an act of violence psychic
liquid fashion liquefaction
as blood seeped from every of his horas
orifices and his body spasmed David
Asquith saw with every fiber of his
being after his heart ruptured into four
in his chest ventricles shredded and
Limp the forms surrounding him began to
dissipate more earthly shadows filling
their wake as his body began to cool in
the night air the blood and vomit
congealing to a waxy shine peace entered
Pontefract park a sense of equilibrium
pervading its green slopes touching the
man-made lake in silent playgrounds a
debt had been paid in this ancient town
forces powerful and ancient had
collected to write the scales until such
time as those scales were tipped again
his body was not discovered for twelve
hours you know what I mean that would
make a really good um like a creep show
segment you know I mean it's like it's
it's like a bad guy like getting his
comeuppance yeah like from the afterlife
yeah yeah I like that a lot that was a
very good story all right so our last
story is by
Dayna Darko I like that name like Donnie
Darko which is also on to be incidental
II that just reminded me this is called
the white wall and there is also some
original artwork to go with this or if
you're watching the video version then I
will put her artwork that she did for
this particular story also because she
has a blog it is silent I am floating
drifting in the darkness the wind
shifting in light sheets across my face
I feel the steady vibrations of tires
rumbling with flight over the pavement
below with my eyes still closed my body
races along a rapid pace and then
finally there's the impression of people
talking in the distance I can also hear
music in the air a horizontal slit opens
to the reality of my dream as my eyes
grew wider it then becomes clear I am in
a car with friends I do not know who
they are as in dreams I barely see them
they could be friends of the present or
of the future no one I would know now
their presence seems to be peripheral in
relation to the road before us perhaps
the persons just represent random
spirits experiencing the same warning
with me or maybe they serve no purpose
at all maybe I might as well be riding
by myself with a phantom driver at the
wheel I only know it feels like my
destiny is to be here on this road
somewhere in the middle of this night
the headlights show the motion of the
slithering trail of glowing white lines
ahead of us as the solid and jagged
snakes wiggle in and out of sight I
notice a white wall faithfully following
parallel to the path closely to the left
of us larger than the tracks of the road
it begins to remind me of a giant white
worm
I am momentarily distracted from the
rapid movement of the car my friends are
laughing I focus briefly on their forms
the traffic lights ahead of us change
like bright red and green planets taking
turns in the black void of space
something is about to happen a glowing
ball of yellow emerges suddenly from an
unseen space and dropped past the lights
and down to earth where it appears to
land somewhere in front of us there is
no discussion we all understand that
each of us wants to find it the green
planet appears and the driver takes his
foot off the brake and with an
big step we move closer to that which we
seek we cruise around in what seems like
an abandoned city there is no sign of
anyone and the lights illuminating the
buildings are dim and an electric gray
there's no sign of the orb only
desolation
then suddenly we appear on that road
again beside the wall I spot something
there beside it just before the wall
disappears into the perspective of night
now it seems as if nothing surrounds us
just the white wall and the thing beside
it
the driver stops sitting in the middle
with no concern that any other human
will come up behind us we peer at it
from here there is no telling what it is
the car shifts so that the headlights
can get a better look
surrounded by a circle of light we can
now tell it as a little girl she is
naked and motionless and she is facing
the wall now I am next to her the lights
circling us both she has still turned
towards the wall so that her face
remains unseen still motionless I sense
it it's not just her but the world that
has gone quiet
we are frozen in this moment there is no
sound except the soft idling of the car
somewhere behind us time passes on and
on then she slowly bends forward her arm
outstretched and her finger pointing to
the ground my eyes only focus on her
finger now and follow it till it touches
the ground with contact there is a
sudden roar and fire shoots out from the
touch moving out from one concentric
circle with the girl in the middle the
surrounding trees the surrounding City
the surrounding everything is consumed
and then it is black and quiet again
that is also a very good man we got some
really good submissions this year
goddamn a lot of talent out there there
really is you guys are awesome need to
send that to some place then make a
screenplay out of it that's what I mean
a lot of these I think will make like
good movies alright so I think so it's
like wait a minute how many like oh crap
okay so we are what are we I think we
are at five and a half hours one that's
sober enough to keep track of all just
barely yeah although yeah I haven't
drunk as much as you yeah because I I
had to read that do more like blur
everybody's stories we
don't have anything else to do we should
wrap this up now because the [ __ ]
because otherwise she's gonna go on
forever oh yeah so okay so hopefully you
guys have enjoyed this ridiculously long
like Halloween show like I said
apologies I did not really expect it to
go on this long but you guys seem to
like that enjoy your Halloween and this
is you know this is really for the fans
anyway you know we're just like trying
to show you guys how much we appreciate
you don't be just like went way
overboard but hopefully you guys enjoyed
our drunken ramblings over two
successive nights and please have a
fantastic and safe Halloween we'll see
you next week and we will see you next
week just like always yep remember we
love you guys and we will see you on the
next show bye and happy Halloween
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]